SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER FIVE WILL
COME TO ORDER. GOOD MORNING IN
RESPONSE TO THE CLOVER NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME MEMBERS ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY TODAY ALL
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE ARE
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM THOSE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASK
THAT EVERY. TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USED. RAISE
YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE PER.
EAST YOU ARE. TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASK A FEW
LIKE TO MUTE. POLICE TO A
BEFORE YOU BE SPEAKING. R. I.
T. PERSON WILL BE YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN. STATE YOUR NAME AND
THEN YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS. TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. I WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE RIVERS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE FOUR ONE SEVEN SIX
OLD NINE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE ANDORRA
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. PLEASE NOTE
THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR
YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND INDEED
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SRVICE FOR HAVE YOU
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT A HEARING IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS. TOOLS
OR TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD
OF WILL NOW BEGIN THE HERE AND
NOW I JUST WANT TO START WITH A
FEW REMARKS- REALLY GRATEFUL TO
CHAIR THE SUBCOMMITTEE ON
TWENTY TWENTY PULL BACK THE
CURTAIN ON MANY INEQUITIES
ACROSS SO MANY OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM
WHERE DEADLY OUTBREAKS HAVE
BEEN DEVASTATING AND ACCESS TO
JUSTICE HAS BEEN DIMINISHED OUR
EMPLOYMENT SYSTEM THAT HAS LEFT
TOO MANY WORKERS WITHOUT
PROTECTIONS. AND FAMILIES
STRUGGLING TO ACCESS THEIR
BENEFITS THE STRAIN ON
EMERGENCY SERVICES AS WE TAKE
ON MULTIPLE CRISIS AS ONE AT
ONCE AND THE IMPACT OF
DECREASED RIDERSHIP IN OUR
VITAL PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEMS IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE
NEED TO DIRECT OUR BUDGET WITH
THESE INEQUITIES ARE FRONT AND
CENTER WE NEED TO MAKE FUNDING
DECISIONS THAT WILL BRING ABOUT
A JUST RECOVERY TO THE PANDEMIC
AND ITS ECONOMIC FALLOUT. THE
DEVIL'S IN THE DETAILS WHEN IT
COMES TO ACCESS TO WORKERS
RIGHTS AND PROTECTIONS TO
CREATING GOOD JOBS TO REMOVING
BARRIERS TO OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
EIGHT MILLION INDIVIDUALS
LIVING WITH A CRIMINAL RECORD
AND POSITIONING OUR STATE TO BE
A LEADER AND PRESIDENT BY HIS
PLAN TO BUILD BACK BETTER I'M
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT THE RENEWED
PARTNERSHIPS WE HAVE WITH THE
NEW ADMINISTRATION. TO
PRIORITIZE THE SHIFT AWAY FROM
JOBS AND HARM OUR COMMUNITIES
AND TOWARD BUILDING A MODERN
RESILIENT INFRASTRUCTURE AND A
CLEAN FUTURE THEY'LL CREATE
MILLIONS OF GOOD PAYING MIDDLE
CLASS JOBS WHILE ALSO ADVANCING
RACIAL EQUITY I THINK WE SHOULD
ALSO ALIGN OUR PRIORITIES WITH
AN EYE TOWARD REIMAGINING OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND ADDRESSING
RACIAL DISPARITIES WE MUST
ENSURE ACHIEVEMENT OF SHORT
TERM AND LONG TERM COST SAVINGS
FROM INMATE POPULATION
REDUCTIONS WHILE RETAINING
ROBUST REHABILITATIVE. AND
RESTORATIVE PROGRAMMING. RISEN
PROGRAMMING SHOULD BE TIED TO
OPPORTUNITIES POST
INCARCERATION. A GOOD MODEL IS
THE MULTI CRAFT CORE CURRICULUM
MC THREE PRE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM. THAT PREPARES
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS FOR
GOOD UNION JOBS IN THE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES. WE
SHOULD EXPAND PROGRAMS A BILL
SKILLS WHILE INSIDE. AND THEN
CONNECTS INDIVIDUALS TO
PATHWAYS TO CAREERS IMMEDIATELY
UPON RELIEF. ELEMENTS ALSO BOND
CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON SUPPORTING
INDIVIDUALS RE ENTERING OUR
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU ALL. FOR
YOUR TIME ON THIS COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR MY TO MY
COLLEAGUES AND OF COURSE TO OUR
BUDGET STAFF AND FOR YOUR
TIRELESS. AND VERY THOUGHTFUL
WORK- THERE ARE NO ITEMS- TODAY
THAT WILL BE VOTED UPON SO THE
IN TODAY'S HEARING WE WILL
BEGIN THE SUB COMMITTEE REVIEW
UP PROCESS FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS IN PUBLIC SAFETY AND
CORRECTIONS WE HAVE PANELISTS
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
WILL PRESENT ON THESE ITEMS.
THOROUGH LET US OF THIS BEGAN
WITH THE PRESENTATION OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S COBIT NINETEEN
DIRECT SPENDING IN THE
CORRECTIONS AND LOCAL PUBLIC
SAFETY AREAS- BELIEVE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WILL BE
PRESENTING. WERE OKAY. GOOD
MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME YES.
HELLO OF MICROSTATION FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS BROUGHT
FORWARD TO CONSOLIDATED REQUEST
FOR GREAT RESOURCES FOR VARIOUS
DEPARTMENTS OF ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND FOR COVERT
RESPONSE. OF THIS AMOUNT TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS IS
REQUESTED FOR CDC ARE WHICH
WILL COVER A VARIETY OF
PURPOSES INCLUDING TESTING FOR
BOTH INMATES AND STAFF.
ADMINISTERING MEDICATIONS
MEDICAL TREATMENT AND VACCINES.
THANKS FOR SURGEONS AND
PROCURING VARIOUS SUPPLIES
INCLUDING PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT. FOR HAPPENED A
CONDITIONAL QUESTIONS BOTH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION AND TO DESCRIBE
THE COMPONENTS PERTAINING TO
THE BORDER STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS I WOULD LIKE TO
TURN IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
JUSTIN EDELMAN. GOOD MORNING HI
FINNCE FOR THE- HE'S THAT IS
GOING TO THE BOARD OF STATE AND
COMMUNITYCORRECTIONS FOR THIS
EFFORT- WE'RE PROPOSING TO
ALLOCATE TWELVE POINT ONE
MILLION GENERAL FUND. TO
PROCESS EARLY RELEASES FROM CDC
ARE YOU POST RELEASE COMMUNITY
SUPERVISION- THIS SUPPORTS
GLOBAL COMMUNITY PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS AND OTHER COUNTY
AGENCIES THAT- WILL HAVE AN
ACCEPTED ISSUE NO- THAT'S- AS
THE RELEASED FROM PRISON
EIGHTEEN COPING NINETEEN. AT
THE FUNDING IS PROPOSED FOR
THAT PERIOD OF JULY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THREE
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE I'M MORE ALSO HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT
THAT SPECIFIC COMPONENT IF YOU.
OKAY- THE L. A. O. IF YOU HAVE
ANY COMMENTS. MOREOVER THE L.
A. O. IT IS NOT THAT HARD TO
FIND YOU MAY BE GOING TOWARD.
COMMUNITY SUPERVISION THIS
OUTCOME THAT NOT GOING TO SIX
YARDS FOR PHCC- ALL RIGHT WE
DONALD- TO SPEAK TO THE FIRST
FLOOR WE CAN. ALSO ENSURE MY
COMMENTS ON IT THE PROPOSAL NOT
RESTRICTION HAS PUT FORWARD IS
BASED ON AN ASSUMPTION THAT
TWENTY SIX HUNDRED PEOPLE THE
RELEASE CHARLIE TO. THESE
COMMUNITIES SUPERVISION BY
COUNTY C. R. C. S. AFTER
RESPONSIBILITY NINETEEN HOURS
UNCERTAIN HOW MANY OF THESE
CASES WILL OCCUR. AFTER THIS
FOR A COUPLE REASONS FOR
EXAMPLE YARDS ALREADY STARTED
MINISTERING VACCINES. TO H. M.
ONCE AGAIN THE NUMBER OF
INMATES HAVE RECEIVED VACCINES
OR MAY NOT BE A NEED FOR THIS
ORDER HE SAYS. IN ADDITION WHEN
DEVELOPING CDCR BUDGET THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION ASSUME THAT THE
EARLY RELEASES WOULD STOP
ACTING THE FOURTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THIS SUGGESTS THAT I
DON'T KNOW WHO NEED. IT THERE
IS NO NEED FOR THE FUNDING FOR
PLCS DURING THE BUDGET YOUR
POLICIES YOUR BUDGET TRIBUTE TO
STRIP OUT THE LOWER INMATE
POPULATION DUE TO CONTINUED
EARLY RELEASES. ETCETERA
COMMITTEE WITH HOLDING ACTION
UNTIL THE MAY REVISION WHEN
THEY SHOULD BE GREATER CLARITY
ON. THE NEED FOR THIS FUNDING.
THANK YOU. OKAY I NOW WILL GO
OUR- COMMITTEE OF- I HAVE A-
THE- A THE CDC ARE PER OF OUR
THERE IN. PARTS OF THIS
ANTICIPATED SPENDING AMOUNT
THAT WILL BE COVERED BY FEDERAL
FUNDING AND HOW MUCH IS THAT.
WHO ONE ALISON HEWITT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE ARE
NOT ABLE AT THIS TIME TO SHARE
ANY SPECIFIC INFORMATION AND
WHAT WE ARE ABLE TO SHARE IS
THAT THE- STATE IN GENERAL AND
ADMINISTRATION IS LOOKING TO
MAXIMIZE FEDERAL FUNDING
WHEREVER POSSIBLE THERE'S TWO
POTENTIAL VEHICLES FOR THAT
THERE IS. AND THE CURRENT RARE
EXCUSE ME CORONAVIRUS RELIEF
FUNDS- WHICH IS KIND OF DIRECT
FEDERAL PAYMENTS TO THE STATE
AS WELL AS POTENTIAL
REIMBURSEMENT THROUGH THE
FEDERAL EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
AGENCY OR FEMA AND WE'RE NOT
ABLE TO SHARE ANY INFORMATION
AT THIS TIME JUST KNOW THAT WE
ARE LOOKING INTO ALL AVAILABLE
OPPORTUNITIES. ANIMAL HOPE TO
SHARE MORE INFORMATION AS IT
BECOMES AVAILABLE. YOU CAN
CHAIR BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
IT OR SOME OF THE RESULT WE
DON'T KNOW THAT WE AT THIS
POINT WE DON'T HAVE ANY
COMMITMENT. FROM THE-
GOVERNMENT OR FEMA AND AS IT
RELATES TO ANY SPECIFIC AMOUNT
I WOULD BE MADE AVAILABLE. FOR
THE AMOUNT THAT'S BEEN
REQUESTED FOR BUDGET YEAR-
WOOD. AND THERE IS SOME
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT WHAT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE AS WELL IN THE
CURRENT YEAR. AND WHEN DO YOU
EXPECT THAT. WE WILL NOW. I'M
ITS INFORMATION IS KIND OF BEEN
GATHERED IN REAL TIME AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS BEEN
PROVIDING REGULAR FISCAL
UPDATES TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
INTENDS TO CONTINUE DOING SO-
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT WITHIN THOSE
FISCAL UPDATES WE MIGHT BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE MORE PRECISE
INFORMATION. OKAY AND THEN WHAT
THE BSE C. PORTION- CAN YOU
EXPLAIN A BIT MORE ON ON THE
TWELVE MILLION HOW YOU
DETERMINED THAT- AMOUNT. THAT
WAS NEEDED THAT YOU SEE IS
NEEDED- ABSOLUTELY JUST MADE
AMENDED PARTMINER FINANCED WHEN
WE WERE DETERMINED THAT TWELVE
MILLION- WHAT WE LOOKED AT AT
THE TIME WHEN WE WERE
DEVELOPING THE BUDGET WATER.
RELEASES FROM CDC ARE ON TO P.
R. C. S. DO YOU RECALL THE
NINETEEN- FOR THE PERIOD OF
OCTOBER A LITTLE BIT OF OCTOBER
AND THE MONTH OF SEPTEMBER I'M
THERE HAD BEEN AN INITIAL KIND
OF BUBBLE IN THE EARLY MONTHS
IN APRIL AND JULY AND SO AFTER
THAT THINGS STARTED TO LEVEL
OUT WE EXTRAPOLATED. THAT THE
LOWER NUMBERS OF RELEASES IN
THE LATER MONTHS IN SEPTEMBER
AND OCTOBER- AND MULTIPLY THAT
BY ABOUT SIX MONTHS FOR THAT IN
THE FIRST SIX MONTHS OF THE
BUDGET YEAR TO DETERMINE THAT
IT WOULD BE ABOUT TWELVE POINT
ONE MILLION. TO PROVIDE FOR THE
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED- INDIVIDUALS WE ARE
ESTIMATING. TO BE RELEASED ON
THE RCS. AND WHAT WHAT IS- WHAT
ARE THE KINDS OF USES THAT
YOUR- THIS MONEY WILL GO TO.
THIS FUNDING IS USED TO SUPPORT
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS AS THEY
TAKE THESE ADDITIONAL CASELOAD
MEMBERS ON- IT CAN BE USED FOR
THINGS LIKE. HAVING LOWER
NUMBERS OF CASELOAD SAID THE
PROBATION OFFICERS ARE ABLE TO
SUPPORT ME INDIVIDUALS ON THEIR
CASELOAD- PROBATION APARTMENTS
ALSO UTILIZED CONTRACTORS AND-
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
TO PROVIDE SERVICES FOR
PROBATIONERS- SO IT'S REALLY UP
TO INDIVIDUAL COUNTIES ON HOW
THEY SPEND THOSE FUNDS. OKAY-
THOSE ARE MY QUESTIONS
COLLEAGUES AND YES GO AHEAD
SENATOR. COULD THANK YOU MA'AM
SURE OF THE QUESTION IT I JUST
WANT TO ESCALATE I THINK YOU
WERE ALLUDING TO THE NOTION OF-
WE WOULD LIKE TO HEAR ABOUT
POSSIBLE FEDERAL BACKFILL
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER SO. AT
LEAST AT THIS COMMUNITY LEVEL I
WOULD CHIME IN TO SUPPORT
SUPPORT THAT BECAUSE
EVERYTHING'S LISTED AS GENERAL
FUND. AT THIS POINT IN
OBVIOUSLY. SO WE'RE GOING BE
MAKING OTHER COMPETING GENERAL
FUND. THE DECISION IS COMING
ALONG- ON THIS ISSUE WE WERE
JUST TALKING ABOUT TURN
SUPPOSED TO CURSE RATIONS A
SUPPORT TO THE COUNTIES-
THROUGH THE PROBATION
DEPARTMENT'S I HEARD ALL THAT
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
DISCUSSION. IN THE PRESENTATION
ABOUT- IT MAY HAPPEN IT MAY NOT
HAPPEN- YOU'LL SEE IN TERMS OF
HOW MANY FOLKS A RELEASE IS IT
GONNA BE TWENTY SIX HUNDRED
OTHER NUMBER I DIDN'T EAR A
LOT OF DISCUSSION OPEN THE
PRESENTATION ABOUT. HELLO THE
DOLLARS PER CAPITA WERE
CALCULATED- IT WORKED WAS THAT
ON THE BASIS OF. SOME KIND OF A
METRIC- IN TERMS OF WHAT
COUNTIES- BUT YOU KNOW OUR
SPENDING NOW I MENTIONED THAT
WOULD BE A MOVING TARGET- I
KNOWN IN THE COUNTY THAT. COULD
I REPRESENT IS AB ONE OH NINE
RE ENTRY CENTER WHICH WOULD BE
THE LIKELY PLACE FOR THOSE
DOLLARS TO GO- BASED ON A LOCAL
DECISION- BUT I HAVE NO IDEA.
WHAT THEY WOULD SAY HI THERE
COST. A PROPERLY WOULD BE YOU
KNOW AND WHETHER THAT ALIGNS
WITH HOME WITH HIS CELL CATION
I CAN JUST GENERALLY.
COMMERCIAL TELEGRAPH MALCOLM
GOING TO BE KIND OF CONCERNED
ABOUT THE IMPLICATIONS. METRICS
ON. A DOLLARS DOLLARS IN
DOLLARS OUT- SO HAS THAT. BUT
YOU KNOW ARE WE WINNING YET OR
EVEN HOW WE ACTUALLY LOOKED AT
THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES AND
FIGURED OUT. WHAT THE REALLY
SPENDING- CURRENTLY IN TERMS OF
REENTRY PROGRAMS. THANK YOU.
WHO AND I THINK THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE QUESTION
AT THIS POINT OKAY JUST A
MOMENT APARTMENT OF FINANCE YES
YOUR QUESTION HIGHLIGHTS A VERY
GOOD QUESTION RIGHT NOW WE
UTILIZED AN EDP FOR AVERAGE
DAILY POPULATION RATE OF TEN
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
DOLLARS PER- INDIVIDUAL
RELEASED ON HERE YES IN THIS
THIS SEEMS IN EIGHTEEN MONTHS-
STAY ON YES BUT WE DON'T HAVE A
BREAK DOWN SPECIFIC TO
INDIVIDUAL COUNTIES IT'S JUST
THAT- RELEASE. COST THANK YOU
AND OBVIOUSLY WE'LL BE
DISCUSSING THIS MORE. THE IN
THE FUTURE IT WOULD BE GOOD IN
IT MAYBE THAT'S- A REQUEST TO
THE ALEJO'S OFFICE IF AT SOME
POINT- WE CAN GET. NOT GRANULAR
PURCHASED ON A COUNTY BY COUNTY-
YOU KNOW REPORT IN TERMS OF
WHAT THEIR ACTUAL EXPERIENCES
IN TERMS OF PER INDIVIDUAL
COSTS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VENTURA TOWING OKAY GOOD. OKAY
THANK YOU- SENATE CRITICIZING.
ANYONE IS THIS CHOI I'M NOT
OWNERS INSURANCE ON THE- THIS
IS THE RIGHT TIME IS TO
GRADUATE I DO A QUESTION BACK
IN- IN PRISON EDUCATION FOR
INCARCERATED. STUDENTS THIS IS
A PROPER NOW'S REALLY REMOTE.
THERE THERE ARE WAY TOO. YEAH.
OKAY THE FIFTY OKAY GREAT OF.
OKAY THE SERVER FROM IS HOLD
HOLD OPEN SO WE WILL MOVE ON TO
OUR NEXT- ISSUE ISSUE NUMBER
TWO- IS ON THE COVER NINETEEN
WORKERS COMPENSATION AT CDC ARE.
WE HAVE- WE HAVE FROM CDCR
THEY'LL MAKE THE PRESENTATION.
THIS YEAR IS. THIS IS ERIC
SWANSON YES MISTER SWANSON
START YOUR- THERE YOU GO OKAY-
THANK YOU YOU SHOULD CHU IS A
REQUEST FOR FIFTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND AND THE
MOUSE OUTLINED IN YOUR GENDER
FOR FUTURE YEARS AND TWENTY
SEVEN LIMITED TERM POSITIONS TO
COMPLY WITH SB ELEVEN FIFTY
NINE. THIS BILL THAT PASSED
LAST SESSION RESTORE A BOTTLE
PRESUMPTION THAT AN EMPLOYEE'S
ILLNESS OR DEATH RESULTING FROM
CORPORATE BANKS YOU KNOW ROSE
OUT OF THE COURSE OF
APPOINTMENT. FOR THE PURPOSES
OF WORKERS COMPENSATION. WITH
ME TODAY IS JANELLE BROWN WHO'S
A SENIOR ATTORNEY WITH THE
OFFICE OF LEGAL AFFAIRS AND
JOANNA SPIEGEL. WHOSE HIEF OF
OUR EMPLOYMENT DISABILITY
MANAGEMENT SECTION WE'RE HERE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
HAVE. SO IT. THAT'S A THREE
YEAR FOR THE PRESENTATION. OKAY
SO- DELEO YEAH THAT'S IT FOR
NOW IF YOU HAVE ANY SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS. OKAY NO FINANCE DO
YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS. LENITION
MATTER DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
NOTHING TO ADD AT THIS TIME BUT
IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS WERE
HAPPY TO ANSWER THEM OKAY. AND
ALEJO. THIS TIME BUT ALSO
HAPPENS TO BE QUESTIONS YEAH.
OKAY I HAVE A OF A FEW
QUESTIONS HERE- CAN YOU EXPLAIN
HOW BECAUSE OF OUR S. B. ELEVEN
FIFTY NINE THAT CHANGES THE
TYPICAL PROCESSES THAT THE CDC
ARE USE USES TO. PROCESS
WORKERS COMPENSATION CLAIMS.
YES THIS IS JANELLE BROWN FROM
CDC ARE AND THE WAY THAT THIS-
SB ELEVEN FIFTY NINE INCREASES
OUR WORKLOAD BECAUSE THERE'S A
SHORTENED TIME FRAME FOR MAKING
A LIABILITY DECISION. GENERALLY
WITH WORKERS COMPENSATION
CLAIMS THE AVERAGE OF DENIAL OR
A LIABILITY DECISION MUST BE
MADE WITHIN NINETY DAYS BUT IN
THIS CASE ACCORDING TO THE
LEGISLATION WE ONLY HAVE THIRTY
DAYS TO ACCEPT OR DENY
LIABILITY AND SO BECAUSE OF THE
COOK NINETEEN ARE QUESTIONS
THAT WERE REQUIRED TO ASK. IT
TAKES US A LOT LONGER TO DO
BACKGROUND QUESTIONS AND WE
NEED ADDITIONAL PERSONNEL TO
ASSIST WITH THOSE COOLEY
NINETEEN RELATED CLAIMS. SO THE
REQUESTED AMOUNT IS TO INCREASE
STAFF. YES THERE'S PERSONAL
THERE'S- CLAIMS PROCESSING FEES
MAINTENANCE FEES FOR THE
ONGOING PROCESSING THERE ARE
ACTUAL WORKERS COMPENSATION
COSTS FOR MEDICAL COSTS-
PERMITTED DISABILITY AND OTHER
ASSOCIATED- COSTS. OKAY I'M I'M
FOR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- HOW
DID YOU DETERMINE THIS BUDGETED
AMOUNT AND WHY IS THE- BUDGETED
AMOUNT FOR THREE YEARS. SO. AS
AN ASIDE THE BULK OF THIS
REQUEST IS DIRECTLY ASSOCIATED
WITH THE WORKERS COMP COSTS AND
MOSTLY MEDICAL COSTS LEGAL
SETTLEMENTS- LEE AT DISABILITY
OR LEGAL COSTS AND DEATH
BENEFITS AS WELL SO THERE ARE
BASED ON DATA THAT OF
ESTIMATING THE NUMBER OF
WORKERS COMP CLAIMS THAT WOULD
BE FILED EACH YEAR AND THEY
LOOKED AT ME MINOR MODERATE AND
SEVERE CASES- TO COME UP WITH
AN ESTIMATE FOR WHAT THOSE
COSTS WOULD ULTIMATELY BE YEAR
OVER YEAR AND THEN IN ADDITION
TO THE TWENTY SEVEN
POSSESSIONS. SO THE REASON THAT
THIS IS A MULTI YEAR PROPOSAL
IS BECAUSE THEIR NEW CLAIMS
THAT WILL BE FILED EACH YEAR-
ONCE. EVEN AFTER A CLAIM IS
FILED THEIR DISABILITY PAYMENTS
THAT WILL OCCUR IN ADDITION IT.
AND AN EMPLOYEE NEEDS TO GET TO
THEIR MAXIMUM MEDICAL
IMPROVEMENT BEFORE LEGAL
SETTLEMENT OCCURS WHICH CAN
TAKE UP TO THREE AND A HALF
YEARS SO IT'S A LENGTHY
PROCESS. SO THERE WILL BE
EXPENDITURES YEAR OVER YEAR BUT
IT IS IT A TEMPORARY FUNDING.
AND ALL DEFERRED TO THE
DEPARTMENT- IF THEY'D LIKE TO
ADD ANYTHING TO THAT. OKAY I
MEAN I GUESS MY QUESTION IS HOW
DO YOU MEAN WE JUST STARTED
GOING THROUGH THIS. IT'S A
BRAND NEW FOR ALL FOR ALL OF
US- HOW DO YOU. HOW DID YOU
DETERMINE THE AMOUNT THAT
YOU'RE ASKING FOR- EXPLAINED A
LITTLE BIT MORE. BECAUSE WE
DON'T KNOW THE IMPACT WE DON'T
KNOW FOR HOW MANY PEOPLE OF
WILL WE DON'T HAVE ANY PRIOR
HISTORY ALL WITH THIS. SO HOW
DO YOU COME UP HOW DID YOU COME
UP WITH THE AMOUNT THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT A LITTLE BIT MORE
PLEASE. I CAN TELL YOU THIS IS
JANELLE BROWN FROM CITY SIR
WHAT WE DID WAS WE HAD SIX
MONTHS OF DATA- BETWEEN MARCH
NINETEENTH WHEN THE GOVERNOR'S.
EXECUTIVE ORDER ORIGINALLY.
OUTLINED THE COLLUDED- COVERAGE.
AND FROM THAT TIME WHEN THE VCP
WAS PREPARED ABOUT SIX MONTHS
OF DATA WAS RECEIVED BY US AND
STATE FUNDS SO WE USE THAT DATA
TO EXTRAPOLATE- THE NUMBER OF
CLAIMS THAT WE BELIEVE WE WOULD
SEE WITHIN THE UP COMING YEAR
OR TWO YEARS- THAT IS COVERED
BY THE STATUTE. AND THEN
BECAUSE THE NORMAL AVERAGE
CLAIM LAST APPROXIMATELY THREE
AND A HALF YEARS WE HAD TO
BUILDING SETTLEMENT COSTS FOR
THE FOLLOWING FISCAL YEARS EVEN
THOUGH- THE STATUTE EXPIRES IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE WE NEEDED
SOME FISCAL. FUNDING FOR THOSE
SETTLEMENTS THAT COME AFTER THE
STATUTE EXPIRES BUT BEFORE THE
CLAIMS HAVE ALL THAT KßT AND
THE SETTLEMENTS ARE NOT. OKAY
THANK YOU- COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS. YES SENATE
CRITICIZING THE MINIATURE. THE
SO I JUST WANT TO GO BACK IN
AND UNDERSTAND A LITTLE MORE
CLEARLY. THEY IT ALONG THE SAME
LINE OF QUESTION I GUESS IS-
THE COMPANY SHOULD BE IMPACTED
SOME LIKE. DURING THE
PRESENTATION WHAT WAS SAID WAS-
IN THE FACTORIES IN THE
POSITIONS THEMSELVES ARE ARE
NEEDED IS BECAUSE- OF THE
TIMELINE THE THIRTY DAY
TIMELINE- IN AN EMPTY I'M
TRYING TO DISTINGUISH HOW THAT
CREATES. MORE THE NEED FOR MORE
POSITIONS RELATIVE TO ACTUAL
CASELOAD. ISN'T IT CAN YOU CAN
YOU. KIND OF SEPARATE THOSE
THINK THOSE TWO THINGS UP FOR
US A LITTLE BIT HOW MUCH MORE
CASE WHAT ARE WE EXPECTING A
YOU TALKED ABOUT EXTRAPOLATING
AND PROJECTING. BUT IT SEEMS TO
ME THE NEED FOR LONG TERM
SUPPORT IS ONLY RELATED TO THE
INCREASING CASELOAD. A SHORT
TERM SUPPORT WOULD. WOULD
CERTAINLY BE NEEDED TO SOME
DEGREE- TO MAKE SURE THAT. OF
THE THIRTY DAY TURNAROUND IS
HAPPENING BUT I'M I'M
STRUGGLING A LITTLE BIT MORE
WITH THE NEED FOR A LONG LONG
TERM SUPPORT. CRITICALLY WITH
CODE CLAIMS WHICH- THE. YOU
KNOW WOULD SEEM TO BE PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD IN TERMS OF IN
TERMS OF THE- ANALYSIS MEDICAL
ANALYSIS AND SO FORTH BUT
THAT'S JUST MY OPINION I'M JUST
TRYING TO THE DISTRICT AT THIS
POINT IS TRYING TO UNDERSTAND-
HOW MUCH LONG TERM IMPACT. IN
TERMS A CASELOAD YOU'RE REALLY
EXPECTING. YES SENATOR
DECISIONAL BROWN FROM CDC ARE I
WOULD SAY THAT- WITH REGARD TO
THE INCREASED WORKLOAD RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE SEEN A 20% INCREASE
IN WORKLOAD WITH THE RETURN TO
WORK WITH METERS WHO ARE THE
PEOPLE AT THE INSTITUTION
RECEIVED THE INITIAL CLAIMS.
AND BEGAN COLLECTING THE DATA
AND PROCESSING THOSE CLAIMS AND
FORWARDING THE INFORMATION
SINCE THEY ARE. ALSO PROCESS IS
THIS FAITH AND SO WITH THE
ADDITIONAL 20% INCREASING HE
SAYS JUST BROKE OPEN OUR RETURN
OR CREATORS ALREADY. THEIR JOBS
ARE ASSIGNED AND HE'S ALREADY
ESTABLISHED AND DISTINCT
CREASES THOSE DUTIES AND THAT
ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD IS MEANT TO
HELP OFFSET. THE STRAIN ON
THOSE ROUTES I RETURN TO WORK
READERS WE'RE DEALING WITH THE
ADDITIONAL FEATURES AS WELL AS
THEIR PER AGAIN SOME OF THAT
INFORMATION AREN'T COLLECTING
AND REPORTING REQUIREMENTS TO
HEADQUARTERS EMPLOYEES AND DOES
NEED TO BE IN POSITIONS CREATED
JUST TO ASSIST WITH THE CODE-
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS AND
PROCESSING OF THOSE PARTICULAR
CLAIMS. THAT'S A THAT'S ON TOP
OF THE ORIGINAL WORK ON THAT WE
ARE HE ADDS AND THAT'S WHY THE
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS. HAVE BEEN
REQUESTED. THE TO THE OF. I
WASN'T WHEN FIFTEEN WAS A DOG
BUT MY UNDERSTANDING OF IT FOR
TO POINT IS THAT. IT MORE TO DO
WITH REBEL PRINCE OF SPEEDING
UP PROCESS. WHAT WOULD CLAY.
PLEASE CALL CLAIMS TWENTY PER
INCREASE OLD OF. REGARDLESS
WHETHER OR NOT LOOKING FIFTY
NINE HAD BECOME LAW. AND IT IS
FREE OKAY. YES TO A DEGREE THAT
CALL THE CLAIMS MAY HAVE
HAPPENED- BUT THE FACT THAT
IT'S A REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION
PUTS THE BURDEN ON THE EMPLOYER
ON CBC ARTS YOU'LL- FIND
INFORMATION ON SUCH AS IF THEY
WERE EXPOSED OUTSIDE OF WORK.
OR IF THE FAMILY MEMBER YOU
KNOW MAY HAVE ACTUALLY AND THEY
ARE. WE'RE SICK BECAUSE OF THE
PUBLIC FAMILY. YOU KNOW ASSETS
TO A WORKER CONDITION AND SO
THE ROBOT PRESUMPTION AGAINST
THE PARTY ON THE- ON CD YOU.
COME UP WITH ANY. AND AGAIN
THAT'S INVESTING AND THAT UT
IT'S NAY TO BE DONE WITHIN
READING EIGHT WHAT SPEEDS UP
THE- EVEN MORE AND WHICH
WORKING. ARE AVAILABLE TO DO
THAT AND THEM MAKE THOSE. IT'S
A BURDEN FOR THE BARK AND SO I
MEAN YOU TO STOP FIRST. AT THIS
IS A- ONCE AGAIN FROM. ARE TOO
I JUST WANTED TO. APPOINT A AS
WELL THAT THESE ARE LIMITED
TERM POSITION- THEY JUST TO DO
WITH THE SHORT WORK IS SO. WITH
COMMON NINETEEN THESE ARE NOT
PERMANENT POSITIONS. THE OTHER
THING WE THERE IS A LOT OF- YOU
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF. THOSE
ATTACHED TO MAKING THIS.
PROPOSAL AND PART OF THE WAY WE
DEALT WITH- THE VARIABLES THAT
ARE- THAT WE MADE WAS WE PUT IT
SORT OF THIS IS KIND OF AN
BUDGET SPEAK BUT WE- PUT.
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE IN HERE
THAT ALLOWS IF THE MONEY ISN'T
NEEDED. BUT IT CAN BE REVERTED
TO THE GENERAL FUND. BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT COLIN IS A FLUID
ISSUE AND- AS WE GO FORWARD-
THERE IS SOME CHANCE THAT- THE-
PROPOSAL WOULD PUT FOR YOU MAY
BE. TOO MUCH OR TOO LITTLE BUT
WE DON'T KNOW AT THIS POINT S
WE TRIED TO. PUT IT IN ITS OWN
BUDGET ITEM WHICH ALLOWS IT TO
BE TRANSPARENT AND SEEN BY
EVERYBODY. AND ALSO- MAKE SURE
THAT- IF THE FUNDING ISN'T
NEEDED WEEKEND I'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE GENERAL FUND. IN IN.
THIS AND HOW DO THOSE TWO
THINGS WHEN. WIN WIN THESE
TEMPORARY POSITIONS ACTUALLY
SUNSET. IS OUR BACKSTOPS
DESERVES A SUNSET DATE AND
SECONDLY. A WHAT WOULD WHAT
WOULD TRIGGER THE- OF THE
RETURN OF THESE DOLLARS THE
GENERAL FUND IS IT IS IT
STIPULATED THAT THAT DECISION
WILL COME BACK TO THIS
COMMITTEE OF ITS THIS COMMITTEE
THAT'S- THIS ANALYZING MOVING
MOVING THE ITEM FORWARD- OKAY
I'M NOT CLEAR ON THAT. PIECE OF
IT. OR IS IT OR IS THIS A SORT
OF THE BUDDY SYSTEM THAT WE
HOPE WE HOPE THAT SOMEBODY
CATCHES IT AND DECIDES TO BRING
IT BACK AND TALK TO US ABOUT
RETURN TO GENERAL FUND I COULD
UNDERSTAND. THE HONOR SYSTEM
YEAH THE OPPOSITION. OKAY YES
SORRY THE OPPOSITION'S
THEMSELVES ARE LIMITED TERM
THROUGH TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR AND THAT
WOULD GO AWAY AT THAT POINT-
THE BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
ITSELF. HAS US NOTIFY THE
LEGISLATURE I BELIEVE- WHEN- IF
THE FUNDS ARE NOT NEEDED.
PERFECT THANK YOU. OKAY WE'RE
GOING TO HOLD OPEN SO WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON. ISSUE THREE. BY
THE CLOSURE OF DO WELL. DO ALL
OF THE CLOSURE OF DHUL
LOCATIONAL INSTITUTE- AND WILL
HAVE A PRESENTATION FROM CDC
ARE I GUESS- MISTER SWANSON
THAT YOU. THAT'S RIGHT- ISSUE.
THREE ALL ON. ISSUE THREE
REQUESTED GENERAL FUND
REDUCTION OF NINETY FIVE POINT
FOUR MILLION AND SIX HUNDRED
AND SIXTY POINT NINE POSITIONS
AND REDUCTIONS IN FUTURE YEARS
AS OUTLINED IN YOUR AGENDA TO
REFLECT THE CLOSURE OF JEWELS
LOCATIONAL INSTITUTE IN TRACY
WITH ME TODAY FOR THIS ISSUE
ARE RELATED PETTUS WHO IS CHIEF
OF OUR WORK FORCE CONSOLIDATION
AND REDUCTION SUPPORT UNIT AND
EDWARD VASCONCELOS WHO IS THE
CHIEF DEPUTY WARDEN. THANK YOU.
SOMEBODY GOING FIRST. AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE ON THE PROPOSAL
ITSELF AGAIN THIS IS DAN IT WAS
PASSED LAST YEAR'S BUDGET ACT-
AND- WE ARE NOW TRYING TO
REFLECT THE REDUCTION MORE AND
MORE PRECISELY THAT WAS AGREED
TO IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET. WELL
LET ME LAY OUT SOME QUESTIONS
AND THEN YOU CAN SORT OF PUT
THEM ALL TOGETHER ENOUGH AND
HOPEFULLY A SINGLE ANSWER. SO
ABOUT WHAT MEASURES ARE IN
PLACE TO MAKE SURE THAT D. V.
I. REMAINS ON TRACK FOR
CLOSURE. IN SEPTEMBER OF THIS
YEAR. WHAT IS THE HOUSING PLAN
FOR THE INCARCERATED- CURRENTLY
HOUSED A DVI. DO YOU HAVE A
DOZEN MINISTRATION HAVE A PLAN
FOR THE LAND IN THE FACILITY
AFTER IT HAS BEEN CLOSED. CAN
YOU EXPLAIN THE NEED FOR
RESOURCES WHEN THE FACILITY IS
IN THE- QUOTE UNQUOTE WARM SHUT
DOWN MODE. AND THEN OF FOR THE
WE'LL LEAVE IT AT THAT FOR- FOR
YOU MISTER SWANSON AND THEN I
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS FOR THE
ALEJO. OR I DIDN'T EVEN CALLING
THEM. SORRY OF FINANCE DO YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS. SORRY WE GO
BACK. IF ANY FRIENDS OR
DEPARTMENT OF FIVE MINUTES CAN
HEAR ME OKAY YES GO AHEAD.
PERFECT OKAY THE SENATOR ALSO-
TO YOUR QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
PLAN FOR LAND AND FACILITY
RESOURCES. AT THIS POINT THE
ADMINISTRATION- PLANS TO KEEP.
DVI IN THE WARM SHUT DOWN MODE
BASICALLY UNTIL A SPECIFIC BIG
DISPOSITION METHOD IS
DETERMINES. WE DON'T HAVE ALL
THE SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS ON
THIS CALL SO WE CAN OF COURSE
GET BACK WITH MORE. INFORMATION
ABOUT THE FACILITY RESOURCES
BUT ESSENTIALLY THE WARM SHUT
DOWN IS DESIGNED TO KIND OF
KEEP THE BASIC FUNCTIONS OF THE
INSTITUTION IN SHAPE SHOULD IT
BE NEEDED INADVERTENCE
SITUATION SO THIS INCLUDES- THE
PLUMBING IN THE ELECTRICAL
SYSTEM DJI'S WASTEWATER
TREATMENT PLANT. THINGS LIKE
THAT. IT HAPPENED ANSWER
FURTHER QUESTIONS. WHAT WERE
YOU CAN ANSWER THE OTHER
QUESTIONS OR IS THAT UP TO HIS
RESPONSE. SORRY I WILL DEFER TO
YOU- MY SEIZE YOUR COLLEAGUES
ON THE OTHER QUESTIONS. OKAY I
THINK- IF WE COULD HAVE A RENEE
PESTS- TAKE A STAB AT SOME OF
YOUR OTHER QUESTIONS THERE. HEY
THIS IS RENEE PATTERSON EASY
ARE. RELATIVES YOUR QUESTION
REGARDS TO THE TIMELINE AND YES
AND TO KEEP US ON TRACK. IT IS
YOUR HAS DEVELOPED A TIMELINE
AND BATCH BEERS YOU PROCESS AND
AT THE LAST ANNUAL DEFINED BY
KELLY JAR. AND WE HAVE
DEVELOPED A TIMELINE TO KEEP
TRACK WITH THE STEPS ERIC.
BIRDS TO- IMPLEMENTING THEY LAY
OFF AND FRAZIER THE FACILITY
AND IT IS SEEN AND IDENTIFYING
THE OPTIONS FOR THE INDIVIDUALS
AND STAFF AT THE LOCATIONS AND
DEPRIVED OF THE- BENEFITS. M.
AS OF TODAY WE ARE CURRENTLY ON
TASK AND WE'RE EACH MEDIA EACH
MILESTONE AND- AS PROJECTED AND
ANTICIPATE THAT THERE IS NO
ISSUE WITH THE CLOSURE DATE OF
SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH. TWENTY-
THANK. TWENTY ONE SORRY ONE
TWENTY ONE SORRY. I THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL ABOUT THE CLOSURE I
AM I CAN ASSIST THOSE AND MY
COLLEAGUE AT BEST ONE BEST AS
WELL AS CAN SPEAK TO AND THE
OTHER QUESTIONS IN REGARDS TO
THE- TRANSFER OF THIS. OF THE
OTHER PIECE. BOB I HAD THE ONE
ABOUT THE HOUSING PLAN FOR A
CAR STRANDED PEOPLE CURRENTLY
HOUSED AT A DVI. YES IT CAN
TAKE THAT QUESTION OKAY.
INVESTORS SULOCHANA CALIFORNIA
PARTNER QUESTIONS A
REHABILITATION SO- I FIRST WANT
TO PIGGY BACK ON ANTHONY'S ACT
COVERAGE BACK ON THE ONE SHUT
DOWN TEAM SO THE ONE SHUT DOWN
IS. TO MAINTAIN THE FACILITY IN
WORKING CONDITION PENDING
DISPOSITION IN THE VAN WE HAD
TO REACTIVATE FOR AN EMERGENCY
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT- BUT THE
TEAM ITSELF IS A LITTLE LARGER
THAN MOST ONE SHUT DOWN TEAMS
PRIMARILY BECAUSE THE SIZE OF
THE FACILITY THE NUMBER OF
BUILDINGS SO FOR EXAMPLE THAT.
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA REENTRY
FACILITY. EXCUSE ME NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA THAT'S THAT'S A-
IT'S A VERY SMALL FACILITY
TWENTY FOUR TOTAL BUILDINGS
DON'T HAVE A WARM SHUTDOWN
CHAMBERS THREE STAFF MEMBERS
WHEREAS AB I HAS TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY TWO BUILDINGS
COMPARED TO TWENTY FOUR
BUILDINGS AT MCW AFTER- THAT
TOTALS US WHERE FOOTAGE OF THE
ACREAGE IS A HUNDRED THREE
ACRES AT. NCW ASSET TO
OCCASIONAL INSTRUCTION IT'S
ALMOST EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
ACRES SO JUST EIGHT A HUGE
DIFFERENCE IN THE SIZE ALSO
JOEL HAS A WASTE WATER
TREATMENT PLANT A REVERSE
OSMOSIS PLANT WATER PLANT I'M
SO THERE ARE LOT LARGER GROUNDS
TO MAINTAIN I'M SURE IT'S JUST
A LOT LARGER SCOPE COMPARED TO
PREVIOUS CLOSURES WE'VE OUT-
BUT- NOW TO MOVE ON TO THE
INMATE POPULATION MOVEMENT. SO
WE ARE WORKING WITH THAT
POPULATION MANAGEMENT UNIT IN
THE DIVISION OF ADULT
INSTITUTIONS WE DEVELOPED A-
REDUCTION PLAN FOR THE PRISON
POPULATION SO IT WILL BE.
SOLELY TRANSFERRING INMATES OUT
THERE'S A QUITE A PROCESS THAT
YOU HAVE TO ENDORSE YOU MAY
DETERMINE THE SECURITY LEVEL
WHAT'S THE BEST INSTITUTION
THEY CAN GO TO. OUR THEIR
PROGRAM HOUSING AT THOSE
INSTITUTIONS GIVEN THE R. CODE
OUTBREAKS THAT ARE CORINNE
PERIODICALLY. AND THEN YOU PUT
HIM UP FOR TRANSFER WE HAVE TO
DO A- PRE JEAN. SCREENING AND
TESTING AND THEN YOU PUT THEM
INTO A QUARANTINE PRIOR TO
TRANSFER. AND THEN YOU GO IN
WITH THE INMATES OUT AND SO WE
HAVE PROXIMATE. LI HUNDRED ONE.
SIXTY IN. ONLINE IN THE LATTER
MINE IN THE WILL HAVE A LITTLE
LESS THAN THAT PROBABLY MORE
LIKE- SIXTY TO EIGHTY A MONTH.
IN THE NEXT FEW MONTHS AND THEN
WILL STEP UP TO ABOUT HUNDRED
SIXTY AMOUNT. ON THROUGH SPRING
ALL THE WAY THROUGH LATE SUMMER
I GET POPULATION DOWN. I'M
SORRY REMIND ME WHAT THE TOTAL
NUMBER THAT NEEDS TO BE. BOMMEL
ARE CURRENTLY THE CURRENT POP
IS THAT LITTLE OVER TWELVE
HUNDRED INMATES. OKAY THANK
YOU- JUST WANT TO GO BACK TO
THE OF THIS WARM SHUT DOWN
MODE- HOW WHEN CAN WE EXPECT A
PLAN AS TO OF MAKING IT OF
PERMANENT CLOSURE. OF IF IT'S
IN THIS WARM SHUTDOWN MODE IS A
LOT OF EXPENSE RELATED TO THAT
ARE AS YOU ALL JUST EXPLAINED
SO HOW ARE WE GOING TO GET TWO
OF THE REAL CLOSURE AND A PLAN
FOR- THE LAND IN THE FACILITY
AFTER IT'S BEEN CLOSED. HI THIS
IS ERIC SWANSON AGAIN- WE ARE-
WALL WE STILL WAIT FOR A
PERMANENT PLAN. AS MR
VASCONCELOS NOTED WE DO NEED TO
TAKE CARE OF THE PROPERTY
ITSELF COULD BE THE PLAN AND
ALL THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
ITSELF IS SEEKING WILL WORK
TOWARDS. FINDING A FINAL
DISPOSITION OF THE PROPERTY BUT
INTEL THAT CDCR NEEDS TO
MAINTAIN THE GROUNDS- THAT HAS
IN THE PAST ARE YOU THIS IS NOT
MY AREA OF EXPERTISE BUT THAT
HAS IN THE PAST. TAKE IT A FEW
YEARS TO HAPPEN- BUT UNTIL IT
DOES WE NEED TO MAINTAIN THOSE
GROUNDS. RIGHT I UNDERSTAND
THAT THAT'S PART OF THE MY
QUESTION IS BECAUSE WE DO NEED
TO MAINTAIN A BECAUSE WE WILL
BE SPENDING MONEY TO. MAINTAIN
THOSE GROUNDS IT SEEMS TO ME
IT'S- INCUMBENT ON US TO GET
THE MAXIMUM SAVINGS THAT WE
SHOULD COME UP WITH A PLAN. SO
THAT WE COULD GET THE SAVINGS
AND MOVE ON TO A GREATER AND
BETTER USE OF THE FACILITIES
SO. I'M NOT SURE WHERE TO GET
THE ANSWER BUT- HOW DO WE COME
UP WITH THE- WHO. ON WHO'S GOT
THE RESPONSIBILITY. TO COME UP
WITH THE PLAN. BOB ON THE ON
THE LAND IN THE FACILITY AFTER
IT'S BEEN CLOSED I COULD JUST
SEE THE SORT OF. HANGING OUT
THERE FOR YEARS AND YEARS AND
WERE WASTED A LOT OF MONEY. ANY
THOUGHTS FROM ANYBODY ON WHERE
THIS ENDS UP AS FAR AS THE PLAN.
AFTER THE CLOSURE TO MAKE SURE
IT'S A CLOSER. I THINK HE WOULD
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCING JUST TO
WAIT A LITTLE BIT SENATOR
DORADO. RESTRICTION DOESN'T
HAVE ANY SPECIFIC PLAN AT THIS
MOMENT THE ONE THING WE WANTED
TO FLAG IS THAT THERE IS A
NUMBER OF USES OF THIS FACILITY
IN THE LAND AND THAT NEEDS TO
BE TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION
MOVING FORWARD. PARTICULARLY AT
THE MOMENT YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
THINGS WE'RE THINKING ABOUT IS
KIND OF SPACE CONSTRAINTS AND
HOW WE UTILIZE SPACE AND IF
THERE'S OPPORTUNITIES I THINK
IT'S ONE OF THE IF. IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'LL BE LOOKING
AT IN TERMS OF. WHAT THE
DISPOSITION FOR THE PROPERTY IS
AS WE SAID WE CAN'T AND THERE'S
NO PLAN AT THIS POINT OTHER
THAN MAINTAINING THE FACILITY
IN ONE SHOT DOWN BUT WE NEED TO
BE VERY THOUGHTFUL I THINK.
MOVING FORWARD ABOUT WHAT WE
END UP DOING WITH THE FACILITY-
IN TERMS OF TRYING TO MAXIMIZE
THE USE OF THE FACILITY IN THE
LANDS FOR CITY TERRACE.
PURPOSES OKAY THANK YOU AND
LASTLY FOR THE L. A. O. CAN YOU
EXPLAIN- YOUR ASSESSMENT THAT
THE STATE. COULD LIKELY CLOSE
THREE MORE STATE PRISONS- BY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. OF AND
THEN WHAT COULD THE STATE DO TO
ENSURE THAT WERE ON APATH TO
CLOSING. MORE THAN TWO PRESENTS.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS CAITLIN
O'NEILL WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- BEFORE HE
TURNED OUT WE DID HAVE A COUPLE
OF RECOMMENDATION OR A FEW
RECOMMENDATIONS RELATED TO THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO.
MENTION THOSE RIGHT NOW OR
SHOULD I COME BACK TO THOSE
AFTER YOUR QUESTION NO I'M
SORRY YOU SHOULD START WITH
THAT. THANK YOU. SO FIRST WHEAT
THERE'S THREE RECOMMENDATIONS
WE FIRST WE RECOMMEND
WITHHOLDING ACTION ON THE
PROPOSED BUDGET ADJUSTMENT
GIVEN THAT THE ADMINISTRATION.
IS PLANNING TO SUBMIT A REVISED
ESTIMATE ADAM THE REVISION.
SECOND WE FIND THAT THE
TWELFTH- POSITIONS REQUESTED TO
SUPPORT THE WORM SHUT DOWN OF
DVI APPEARS EXCESSIVE GIVEN
THAT CDCR REPORT HAS REPORTED
TO US THAT IT CURRENTLY ONLY
USES. TWO POSITIONS TO SUPPORT
THE WORM SHUT DOWN OF THAT
ANOTHER PRESENT- THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S FACILITY
ALTHOUGH MR VASCONCELOS. JUST
MENTIONED THREE POSITIONS SO
THE LITTLE BIT OF- IT IN I'M
CERTAINTY THERE BUT- REGARDLESS
IT'S FAR SMALLER AND FAR FEWER
POSITIONS THAN THE TWELVE
BETTER REQUESTED AND WE DO
UNDERSTAND THAT D. V. I. IS A
LARGER. PRISON BUT NONETHELESS
THE DEPARTMENT HASN'T BEEN ABLE
TO PROVIDE- JUSTIFICATION FOR
ALL TWELVE- IN OTHER WORDS
CONNECTING THE SIZE OF THE
FACILITY TO THE NEED FOR THOSE.
THAT POSITIONS WE THINK THAT
FIVE POSITIONS APPEARS
REASONABLE SO WE RECOMMEND
REJECTING SEVEN OF THE
POSITIONS WHICH WOULD REDUCE
THE REQUEST BY. SIX HUNDRED
FORTY THOUSAND IN THE BUDGET
YEAR AND. EIGHT HUNDRED THIRTY
THOUSAND ANNUALLY THEREAFTER.
ARE THERE RECOMMENDATION TO THE
FUTURE OF THE DVI FACILITY AS
YOU YOU KNOW IT'S AS IS ALREADY
BEEN DISCUSSED THERE IS NOT
CURRENTLY A PLAN. FOR THE
ULTIMATE DISPOSITION- DVI OR
THE SECOND PERSON THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS COMMITTED TO
CLOSING. I SO WE RECOMMEND
ADOPTING BUDGET TRAILER
LEGISLATION REQUIRING CDCR TO
REPORT BY JANUARY TENTH OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. ON WHAT
OPTIONS IT'S CONSIDERING FOR
THE ULTIMATE ULTIMATE
DISPOSITION- DVI AS WELL AS THE
SECOND PRESENT IT PLANS TO
CLOSE. WE THINK THIS WILL HELP
AVOID UNNECESSARY SPENDING ON
WARM SHUT DOWN. DID YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS ON ON THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS OR SHALL I
PROCEED TO ANSWERING YOUR
QUESTIONS. I THINK YOU CAN GO
AHEAD AND ANSWER MY QUESTIONS.
OKAY SO THE FIRST QUESTION WAS
CAN ADD CAN I EXPLAIN- OUR
ASSESSMENT THAT THE STATE COULD
CLOSE FIVE PRESENTS I BELIEVE
WAS THE QUESTION YEAH- OUR OUR
ASSESSMENT IS BASED ON CCAR'S
PROJECTIONS OF THE INMATE
POPULATION THROUGH JUNE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. AND JUST TO
ELABORATE ON THAT A LITTLE BIT
MORE AND THE POPULATION IS
CURRENTLY VERY LOW AND TO
ENSURE AWARE DUE TO. AB
RESPONSES THAT THE STATE HAS
TAKEN IN- TO A DRESS CODE IN
THE PRISONS. SUCH AS THAT
DEFICIT SPENDING THAT INTAKE
FROM COUNTY JAILS. AND THOSE
ARE TEMPORARY MEASURES THAT
WILL EAT- BE REMOVED
EVENTUALLY. HOWEVER PREVIOUSLY
ENACTED AND PLANNED POLICY
CHANGES ARE EXPECTED TO REDUCE
THE AMOUNT OF TIME THAT INMATES
ARE REQUIRED TO SPEND IN PRISON
GOING FORWARD AND- AS THOSE
POLICY CHANGES TAKE HOLD
THEY'RE EXPECTED TO BRING TO
PUT DOWNWARD PRESSURE ON THE
INMATE POPULATION SUCH THAT
EVEN AFTER THE TEMPERING CODE
RELATED MEASURES GO AWAY THE
POPULATION IS EXPECTED TO MAIN
RELATIVELY LOW REACHING AROUND
A HUNDRED THOUSAND BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE WHICH IS A COUPLE
TENS OF THOUSANDS LOWER THAN
PRE PANDEMIC LEVELS. AND SO.
PREVIOUS INMATE POPULATION
DECLINES HAVE BEEN ACCOMMODATED
BY REMOVING INMATES FROM
CONTRACT PRISONS BUT THE STATE
IS ON THE VERGE OF REMOVING THE
FINAL INMATES FROM CONTRACT
PRISONS THIS YEAR SO GOING
FORWARD- WHEN DECLINES
ACCUMULATE TO THE SIZE OF A
FROM TWO OF THE- CAPACITY OF
ONE PRISON ESSENTIALLY THE
STATE COULD ACCOMMODATE THE
DECLINE BY CLOSING PRISONS. AND
GIVEN THE MAGNITUDE OF THE
DECLINE THAT'S PROJECTED WE
ESTIMATE THAT THE STATE COULD
CLOSE AROUND FIVE PRISONS. OVER
THE NEXT THREE YEARS- THOUGH
THE ACTUAL AMOUNT COULD BE
HIGHER OR LOWER DEPENDING ON
THE SPECIFIC FACILITIES. THAT
ARE CHOSEN AND THE AND THE
CAPACITY OF THOSE FACILITIES.
YOUR MEN I BELIEVE YOUR SECOND
QUESTION. WAS HOW THE STATE CAN
INSURE THAT IT'S ON IT STAYS ON
A PATH TO CLOSING THESE PRISONS
WAS THAT CORRECT YES YES. SO S.
S. SIGNIFICANT DRIVER OF THE
POPULATION DECLINE THAT'S
PROJECTED IS. HE PLANNED BUT
NOT YET IMPLEMENTED- EXPANSION
TO INMATE. TWO CREDITS WHICH
ARE- TIME THAT INMATES CAN EARN
OFF THEIR PRISON SENTENCE FOR
MAINTAINING GOOD BEHAVIOR WHILE
INCARCERATED. AND THAT- WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE- WAS PLANNED TO
BE IMPLEMENTED JANUARY ONE OF
THIS YEAR BUT GIVEN THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAD TO SHIFT ITS
ATTENTION TO ADDRESSING COVET
THAT IMPLEMENTATION DATE HAS
BEEN PUSHED BACK TO MARCH- SO
TO THE EXTENT THAT THAT DATE
SLIPS FURTHER. THAT WOULD
LIKELY- IMPACT THAT POPULATION
DECLINING COULD DELAY THE
STATE'S ABILITY TO CLOSE A
PRISON SO ONE THING THE STATE
CAN DO IS SIMPLY- TRY TO
PREVENT THAT IMPLEMENTATION
DATE FROM GETTING PUSHED
FURTHER BACK. AND THEN BEYOND
THAT TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
POPULATION DECLINES DON'T
MATERIALIZE AS PROJECTED. THERE
ARE A VARIETY OF OPTIONS THAT
THE STATE HAS TO. PUT THE STATE
OR KEEP KEEP IT ON TRACK OF PUT
IT BACK ON TRACK TO CLOSING
THOSE PRESENTS AND THEY
GENERALLY FALL INTO THREE
CATEGORIES. THE FIRST IT WOULD
BE TO MAKE FURTHER CHANGES TO
REDUCE THE INMATE POPULATION
WHICH- THAT COULD BE.
SENTENCING CHANGES FOR- OF
WHICH THERE'S A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT OPTIONS. SECOND WOULD
BE TO HOUSE MORE INMATES. IN
FACILITIES OUTSIDE OF THE STATE
OWNED PRISONS FOR EXAMPLE THE
STATE COULD EXPAND YOU SAYS
IT'S ALTERNATIVE CUSTODY
PROGRAM WHICH ALLOWS CERTAIN
INMATES TO SPEND THE LAST YEAR
OF THEIR SENTENCE IN THE
COMMUNITY UNDER THE SUPERVISION
OF A PRO AGENT- AND THEN THE
THIRD OPTION WOULD BE TO.
REDUCE WIDER. I IS OFTEN CALLED
THE BUT FOR WHICH AND BY THAT I
MEAN THAT GIVEN A FEDERAL COURT
ORDER RELATED TO IN PRISON
OVERCROWDING THE STATE IS.
LIMITED TO HOLDING NO MORE THAN
ABOUT A HUNDRED SIXTEEN
THOUSAND INMATES IN ITS STAND
STATE OWNED PRISONS. BUT AT
GIVEN THAT THERE CAN BE
FLUCTUATION IN THE POPULATION
THE STATE TYPICALLY SO IN PRE
CODE RED AND HOLDS- ARETE ABOUT
TWO THOUSAND INMATES FEWER THAN
THAT LIMIT IN ITS PRISONS IN
ORDER TO GIVE ITSELF SOME
BUFFER IN THE EVENT THAT THE
POPULATION INCREASES
UNEXPECTEDLY. SO ONE OPTION
WOULD BE TO SIMPLY HOT- OPERATE
A SMALLER BUFFER HOUSING SAME-
A THOUSAND INMATES FEWER THAN
THE LIMIT- THE STATE WOULD
POTENTIALLY WANT TO HOWEVER
TAKE OTHER ACTION TO MITIGATE
THE RISK OF VIOLATING THE COURT
ORDER. SUCH AS FORMING
AGREEMENTS WITH COUNTY
SHERIFF'S TO DELAYED TRANSFER
OF INMATES IN THE EVENT THAT
THE POPULATION DOES APPROACH
THAT COURT ORDERED LIMIT. OKAY
EIGHT THOSE ARE GREAT
SUGGESTIONS GREAT
RECOMMENDATIONS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF. FINANCE. I'M SORRY LET
ME SHATTER DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THANK YOU I'D LIKE TO
RESPOND TO ADD TO THAT PART OF
THE ALLEY OWES RECOMMENDATION
SO AS WE KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY CURRENTLY DUE TO
TEMPORARY POPULATION REDUCTION
AND JUST FUTURE ONGOING AB
POPULATIONS ACTIONS IN THE
EFFECTS OF KOVIN. M. CDCR NEEDS
TO HAVE THE ABILITY TO HAVE
FLEXIBILITY TO MANAGE THEIR
INSTITUTION POPULATION AS
SAFELY AS POSSIBLE DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND EVEN AFTER THAT
PANDEMIC SO THE ADMINISTRATION
BELIEVES IT'S- PREMATURE TO
IDENTIFY IT TIMELINE FOR FUTURE
PRISON PRISON CLOSURES BEYOND
THE SECOND CLOSURE PLAN FOR
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE.
ULTIMATELY THE POPULATION
CULVERTED AND OTHER FACTORS
WILL DICTATE. ANY FUTURE
CLOSURES BEYOND THAT SO
ALTHOUGH THE L. A. R. WAS
RECOMMENDING THREE ADDITIONAL
CLOSURES BEYOND THE TWO ALREADY
PLANNED THEIR ADDITIONAL COURT
PRESSURES THAT EXIST THAT NEED
TO BE TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION.
EACH INSTITUTION CURRENTLY HAS
ISOLATION SPACE TO ALLOW. FOR
ANY OUTBREAKS OF COLD DEAD AND
EVEN ONCE EVERYONE IS
VACCINATED THERE COULD STILL BE
RISKS OF OTHER AIRBORNE ELLIS'S
WHICH CAN BE DIFFICULT TO
CONTAIN WITHIN A PRISON. SO
WE'RE STILL CONSIDERING
DIFFERENT THE USE OF DIFFERENT
BANDS WHICH ARE POTENTIALLY
MORE AT RISK AND RIGHT NOW THE
COURTS ARE WATCHING AND LOOKING
AT HOW THESE ISSUES WILL BE
HANDED IN THE LONG TERM. SO
WERE RELUCTANT TO CLOSE ANY
ADDITIONAL PERSONS BEYOND THAT
TO YOU BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE COURTS WILL DO SO
THERE'S A LOT TO CONSIDER
MOVING FORWARD- JUST. BEYOND
STRICTLY THE POPULATION. THANK
YOU. SURE YOU'RE RAISING THE
ISSUES OF SAFETY- FOR EVERYONE-
BOTH THE STAFF AS WELL AS THE
AS THE INCARCERATED- I THINK WE
JUST NEED TO MOVE TOWARDS MORE
CERTAINTY IT DOESN'T MEAN IT'S
AN ABSOLUTE OR ITS AND FLEXIBLE
WE GIVE A DIRECTION- AND I
THINK THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ALL
ASKING ABOUT FOUGHT LET'S WHAT
I'M ASKING ABOUT- COLLEAGUES.
IN THE QUESTION NOTHING OKAY
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH WE'RE
MOVING ON TO ISSUE WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE VOTING ON THAT LAN
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR THIS IS ON
CORRECTIONAL STAFF TRAINING AND
JOB SHADOWING. AGAIN MISTER
SWANSON I BELIEVE. YEAH CAN'T
HEAR YOU MISS. THIS IS. ONE
ONE. SORRY ABOUT THAT THAT
ALWAYS HAPPENS IT WILL GIVE YOU
A PASS ONE TIME NO DISCUSS. IT
ALL RIGHT GO AHEAD. ISSUE FOR
REQUESTED AUGMENTATION OF
NINETEEN POINT NINE MILLION
GENERAL FUND AND FIFTY NINE
POSITIONS IN TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. ROOF
DEPARTMENTAL TRAINING OF
INSTITUTIONAL BASED CUSTODY
STAFF SO THIS REQUEST REALLY
CONSIST OF THREE COMPONENTS
IT'S THE REACTIVATION OF THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S
FACILITY FOR SOME HANDS ON IT
REALITY BASED TRAINING- NUMBER
TWO IMPLEMENTATION OF A JOB
SHADOWING PROGRAM FOR NEW
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS. AND
NUMBER THREE INCREASE SINCE-
COMMISSION ON CORRECTIONAL
PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS AND
TRAINING WHICH WILL NOW
REFERRED TO AS C. POST IS THAT
SUCH A LONG NAME. TO PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT TO CUSTODY AT NON
CUSTODY STAFF. WITH ME TODAY
FOR THIS ISSUE IS AN AGREED A
DUBLIN OHIO- WHO'S EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF C. POST AND
CRISTINA ARROYO WAS A
CORRECTIONAL BUSINESS MANAGER
AT OUR- TREATING GROUP- WE'RE
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. OKAY IT'S THE CAN
YOU EXPLAIN WHAT IT IS THAT THE
OUTCOMES THAT YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR AND HOW DO WE MEASURE WELL
KINDA METRICS OR WHAT YOU KNOW
HOW DO WE MEASURE IF YOU'RE
SUCCESSFUL AND WHAT YOU'RE
LOOKING TO DO WITH THIS- WITH
THIS TRAINING. THANK YOU
SENATOR IN RANDOM AND I- FROM
RUNNING SECULAR DIRECTOR FROM
SEACOAST- I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
TWO THINGS YOU HAS YOUR
QUESTION AND YOU KNOW WHAT ARE
WE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH WITH
THIS- PROPOSAL. AND IT'S
ESSENTIALLY MORE CONFIDENT AND
BETTER PREPARED CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS WHEN THEY ASSUME
THEY'RE INDEPENDENT POST OF THE
INSTITUTIONS- RIGHT NOW THEY
ARE PROVIDED A BASIC ACADEMY
TRAINING AT ANY COMPANY SETTING
THAT IS NOT PRESENT- THEREFORE
IT IS HARD TO REPLICATE SOME OF
THE MORE HIGH RISK ESSENTIAL
FUNCTIONS OF A CORRECTIONAL
OFFICER- THAT THEY MAY BE
ASSIGNED UPON ARRIVING TO AN
INSTITUTION. THIS PROPOSAL
SERVES TO CLOSE THAT GAP IN
TRAINING BY ONE PROVIDING THEM
PROBLEM BASED LEARNING
SITUATIONS IN A REALITY BASED
TRAINING- JUST SILLY. AND ALSO
PROVIDING THEM- ON THE JOB
TRAINING THROUGH JOB SHADOWING
WHERE THEY'LL ACTUALLY BE
LEARNING THEIR ROLE AS A
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICER AT
THE INSTITUTION WHERE THEY WORK.
I'M IN A REAL TIME ENVIRONMENT.
AND JUST PREPARE TO DO. THIS OF
THE ENHANCED ENSURE. BY WAY OF
THE INTERVIEWS WITH THE NEW
OFFICERS POST THEIR TRAINING
AND JOB SHADOWING- INTERVIEWING
THEIR SUPERVISORS AND ALSO AND
THEY'RE HIRING AUTHORITIES ON
WHETHER OR NOT THE TRAINING
ENHANCEMENTS. HAVE BEEN TRACKED
RESULTED IN A BETTER PREPARED
OR MORE PREPARED CORRECTIONAL
PEACE OFFICER TO ASSUME AN
INDEPENDENT- POST AND SOME OF
THESE MORE HIGH RISK OR HIGH
CRITICAL POSTS- AND THOSE
INTERVIEWS ARE THINGS THAT WE-
HAVE CONDUCTED- PRE THIS
PROPOSAL TO FIND OUT WHAT THE
NEEDS WERE. AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE CAN CIRCLE BACK AND-
CONDUCTS SIMILAR INTERVIEWS TO
FIND OUT WHETHER OR NOT THIS
ENHANCEMENT HASN'T. DROPPED
CLOSE THAT GAP IN TRAINING.
THANK YOU- WHAT IS LED TO YOU
PROPOSE IN THIS- I GUESS I'M
NOT SURE WHY- I DON'T HERE IS
WHAT'S THE PROBLEM WE'RE TRYING
TO SOLVE OR WHAT'S THE ISSUE
WE'RE TRYING TO THE SOLVE WITH
THIS PROPOSAL I UNDERSTAND.
BASICALLY IN TRAINING IN
GENERAL YOU ALWAYS LOOK FOR YOU
KNOW BETTER TO BUT I'M NOT SURE
I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE REALLY
TRYING TO TRYING DO HERE DO YOU
TO ACCOMPLISH. AND IS. THE
RESULT IT'S THE RESULT OF WHAT
THERE'S- PROBLEMS WHAT WHAT ARE
THE ISSUES AND PROBLEMS THAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS BY
CHANGING. THE SYSTEM AND THE
TRAINING. THANK YOU SO- OVER
THE COURSE OF THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS- TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN AND THEN AGAIN TO THE
EXTENT WE COULDN'T TWENTY WITH
ACTUALLY TRAVELED TO OVER
TWENTY FIVE OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS- INTERVIEWING-
BOTH NEW OFFICERS AND
SUPERVISORS THE HIRING
AUTHORITY ABOUT THE BASIC
TRAINING EXPERIENCE- BOTH
MYSELF AND THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF PEACE OFFICER SELECTION AND
EMPLOYEE DEVELOPMENT CONDUCTED
THOSE INTERVIEWS- WE ARE
SEEKING FEEDBACK ON HOW
TRAINING CAN BE IMPROVED TO
BETTER PREPARE OUR OFFICERS FOR
THE PRISON ENVIRONMENT. AND
ALSO TO ENHANCE INMATE SAFETY-
BETTER PREPARED CORRECTIONAL
PEACE OFFICERS- SHOULD RESULT
IN- MORE SAFETY FOR OUR STAFF
AND OUR INMATES I'M HOUSING OR
FACILITIES SO FROM THESE
INTERVIEWS THERE ARE SEVERAL
COMMON THEMES THAT EMERGED ONE
OF THE MOST APPARENT TEAM WAS
THAT WE NEEDED GREATER HANDS ON
PRACTICE IN SOME OF THESE
ESSENTIAL FUNCTIONS. THAT HAVE
A PSYCHOMOTOR COMPONENT TO- YOU
KNOW MAKING DECISIONS AND THEN
REACTING TIMELY AND SITUATIONS
THAT OCCUR. IN AN INSTITUTION
ENVIRONMENT. YEAH GREATER IN ON.
SKILLS BOTH WITH START WITH OUR
NON TEST STAFFER MEDICAL STAFF
AND OF COURSE OUR INMATES-
BETTER TRAINING ON JUDGMENT
WHICH- FEEDS INTO PROBLEM BASED
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT EVENTS
STYLE LEARNING OR PUTTING OUR
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS OR
SKEWS ME OUR CADETS. AN ACTUAL
SCENARIOS WHERE THEY'RE HAVING
TO MAKE REAL TIME DECISIONS
ABOUT HOW TO SECURE THE SAFETY
AND SECURITY OF THE PRESENT AND
ALSO- DE. AS WE KNOW WE HAVE
INSTITUTIONS WITH DIFFERENT
MISSIONS- WITH DIFFERENT INMATE
POPULATIONS AND DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS AVAILABLE TO REMAIN
POPULATIONS AND NOT ALL OF THAT
CAN BE REPLICATED IN ACADEMY
STARTING- THERE ARE CERTAIN
POSTS THAT CAN'T BE REPLICATED
ECONOMY CONTROL LOSES ONE OF-
TRANSPORTATION OF INMATES- SOME
OF OUR MEDICAL SHOULD ADD
MEDICAL PROGRAMS WITHIN OUR
INSTITUTIONS. I'M SO WHAT DOES
TRAINING PROPOSAL DOES IS IT-
SERVICE TO CLOSE THE GAP
BETWEEN WHAT WE CAN OFFER AT AN
ACADEMY WHICH IS MORE KIND OF
CLASSROOM AND OR DISCUSSION
BASED LEARNING- TO PUT THEM IN
A REAL LIFE TRAINING
ENVIRONMENT WHICH WE KNOW FROM
INTO ADULT LEARNING
PERSPECTIVE. IS A BETTER WAY
FOR US TO CONVEY INFORMATION
AND EXPECT OUR NEW CORRECTIONAL
PEACE OFFICERS TO BE ABLE TO
PERFORM THESE ABILITIES NOT
JUST HAVE THE KNOWLEDGE BUT
ACTUALLY EXECUTE IN AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE THERE
ESSENTIAL FUNCTIONS REQUIRED
THIS LEVEL OF- PROBLEM. SOLVING
AND REACTIONS. OKAY AND THEN- A
FINAL FOR ME FOR ME IS- THIS
SEEMS TO BE FOCUSED ON NEW
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS OR
CADETS. BOB HOW ABOUT THE
EXISTING- OFFICERS. TO OUR
EXISTING OFFICERS GO THROUGH
ANNUAL TRAINING EVERY YEAR-
SERVICE TO KIND OF REFRESH IF
YOU WILL SOME OF THOSE MORE AND
CRITICAL ESSENTIAL FUNCTIONS-
USE OF FORCE COMMUNICATION DE
ESCALATION- YOU KNOW SOME OF
OUR NEWER TRAINING ON DIVERSITY
AND TRANSGENDER POPULATION SIX
ARCHER. NEARLY THIS PROPOSAL
FOCUSES ON INEXPERIENCED NEW
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
THAT HAVE NEVER WORKED IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT YOUR EXISTING STAFF
HAVE DEVELOPED OVER TIME THE
EXPERIENCE TO BETTER
COMMUNICATE WITH INMATES WITH
MEDICAL STAFF NON CUSTODY
EXCEPT FOR A- SO THEY HAVE
ALREADY LEARNED SOME OF THESE
ON THE JOB TECHNIQUES JUST BY
ROUTE BY. MEANS OF GOING
THROUGH THEIR PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM AND BEING AT THE
INSTITUTION PERFORMING THEIR
DUTIES- THIS PROPOSAL SERVICE
YOU PROVIDE A TRAINING
COMPONENT THAT- SHORES UP THIS
IDEA OF TRIAL AND ERROR WHILE
ON THE JOB- WHERE RISKS ARE ARE
ARE OFTEN TIMES HIGHER IF
MISTAKES ARE MADE- SO THAT THEY
HAVE A TRANSITIONAL TRAINING.
BEFORE THEY'RE LEFT INDEPENDENT
ON THE COAST. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH COLLEAGUES ANNIE YES
SENATOR NEWMAN. AND I'M SURE
OKAY QUICK QUESTION SHOULD
GUIDE THE ANNOUNCES WE GOT
NOTES THAT THERE ARE FINES FOR
THIRTY THREE CORRECTIONS
SERGEANT POSITION ONE PER
PERSON- ADDED NOTES THAT IN
ADDITION TO THE JOB SHARING
PROGRAM THEY WOULD PERFORM
VARIOUS OTHER DUTIES RELATED TO
STAFF TRAINING THAT THE
DEPARTMENT CAGE. HAVE GROWN IN
RECENT YEARS ON A LEVEL THAT
CAN BE CURRENTLY COMEDY WHAT
ARE THOSE DUTIES I WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE NOT-
UNINTENTIONALLY CREATING- SOME
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT DON'T
DIRECTLY RELATE TO THIS BUDGET
REQUEST. REXEL RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE. AND IN SERVICE- TRAINING
OFFICES AT EACH OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS. BETTER STAFFED
WITH ONE SERGEANT ONE
CORRECTIONAL TRAINING SERGEANT-
THAT SURGEON IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
EXECUTING TRAINING FOR BOTH
CUSTODY AND NON CUSTODY STAFF-
AND THE TRAINING IS YOU KNOW
VERY IN TERMS OF. THE TYPE OF
TRAINING THAT WE PROVIDE TO THE
LEVEL OF CARE AND- CUSTODY
VERSUS NON CUSTOMERS AS MEDICAL
STAFF. TO THE CURRENT I. S. T.
OFFICES AS THEY'RE CALLED- ARE
REALLY STRUGGLING TO KEEP UP
WITH A LOT OF THE TRAINING
RESPONSIBILITIES ESPECIALLY AS
OF LATE- THERE ARE ALSO
RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL OF OUR
AUDITS. AND THAT GOAL LONGER
COINCIDE WITH TRAINING OR
COMPLIANCE AUDITS- EQUIPMENT
SITTING ON IT SANTA COULDN'T
SITTING FOR CUSTODY STAFF. THEY
ALSO MUST PROVIDE INSTRUCTION
AND ALL THE COURSES THAT ARE
OFFERED THROUGHOUT THE YEAR SO
WE TRAIN TWELVE MONTHS OUT OF
THE YEAR- ALL OF THE STAFF
WITHIN THE INSTITUTION. AND AS
YOU WELL KNOW SOME INSTITUTIONS
HAVE YOU KNOW GREATER THAN
TWELVE HUNDRED STAFF- AT THE
FACILITY- AND SO WITH THIS
PROGRAM JOB SHADOWING. AND ALSO
RESPONSIBILITIES OVER
PARTNERSHIP WHERE. NEW STAFF
WOULD BE PROVIDED ON THE JOB
TRAINING. OVER THE COURSE OF
TWO YEARS WHICH IS THEIR
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM. CALLED
RELATED IN SACRAMENTO TRAINING
AND THAT TRAINING IS REALLY
SUPPOSED TO EMPHASIZE- HOW TO
GET NEW STAFF BETTER PREPARED
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT. SO IT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE TAILORED TO THE
NEEDS OF OUR NEW CORRECTIONAL
PEACE OFFICERS. WITH ONE
TRAINING SERGEANT AT OUR
INSTITUTIONS TODAY IT'S JUST
NOT FEASIBLE FOR THEM TO BE
ABLE TO EXECUTE A JOB SHADOWING
PROGRAM. PROVIDE RELATING
SUPPLEMENTAL TRAINING TO
APPRENTICES THAT RESIDE IN THE
INSTITUTION OVER TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS. AND ALSO SUPPORT ALL OF
THE OTHER TRAINING NEEDS AND R.
I. S. T. OFFICES. SO THIS
PROPOSAL HELPS UP SOME OF THE-
STAFF DIVISION THAT WE SEE.
THAT THOSE ARE CLEARLY.
FUNCTION SO. WHAT THINKING. HAS
BEEN DONE WHAT IF YOU DON'T GET
THE FULL ALLOCATION FOR ALL
THIRTY THREE CORRECTION
POSITIONS HOW WE ADDRESSES
OTHER NEW AGE. YOU KNOW WE WILL
HAVE TO LOOK AT THAT AND CREATE
SOME SORT OF- GAP ANALYSIS
BETWEEN WHETHER OR NOT AND WE
CAN PROVIDE SUPPORT. FROM
ANOTHER AREA BUT AGAIN ANY TIME
YOU'RE TRANSITIONING ANY
MANPOWER YOU ARE DEPLETING IT
FROM SOMEWHERE ELSE AND
TRAINING IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT
ASPECT OF THE WORK THAT WE DO
IN CDC ARE THAT- IT JUST
DOESN'T SEEM FEASIBLE FOR US TO
BE ABLE TO. REALLY SUPPORT THE
NEEDS OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO I
THINK CLOSE THE GAP ON TODAY-
WITH TRAINING AND WITH
PROVIDING CONTINUING
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
OUR CURRENT CUSTODY FOLKS AND
NON CáC FOLKS ARE
INSTITUTIONS- THE ANSWER
QUESTION I DON'T KNOW WHERE IT
WOULD COME FROM. SHOULD THE
DOCUMENT. THANK YOU. OKAY OF-
I'M SORRY HOW DO I KEEP LEAVING
THE L. A. L. SORRY L. A. L.
PLEASE. I'M DRIVE KEEP DROPPING
OFF NOT A PROBLEM AT SO I'M
GOING TO STRUCTURE MY COMMENTS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS- AROUND
EACH COMPONENT OF THE PROPOSAL
AND THEN ISSUE A ONE OVER
ARCHING COMMENT AND
RECOMMENDATION THE FIRST
COMPONENT IS THE RESOURCES FOR
THE POST WHICH WE THINK WOULD
HELP THE DEPARTMENT AT OUR
EXCUSE ME SEACOAST BETTER MEET
IF LEGISLATIVE MANDATE SO WE DO
RECOMMEND APPROVING THOSE
RESOURCES BUT WE HAVE CONCERNS
THAT THE PROPOSAL DOESN'T
FACILITATE LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT. AND THAT'S BECAUSE
THE RESOURCES WOOD OUR HOPE HE
POST BETTER MONITOR METRICS
RELATED TO EMPLOYEE PERFORMANCE
AND TRAINING BUT THERE ISN'T A
PLAN TO KEEP THE LEGISLATURE
INFORMED OF THAT THOSE
FINDINGS. AND SO AND THIS IS OF
PARTICULAR CONCERN GIVEN THAT
THE- THERE'S BEEN SOME. I OF
VARIOUS PRISONS RELATED TO
STAFF MISCONDUCT- THAT COULD BE
TIED TO TRAINING DEFICIENCIES
SO WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO BE KEPT WELL
INFORMED OF. ISSUES RELATED TO
STAFF PERFORMANCE AND TRAINING.
SO WE RECOMMEND PASSING TRAILER
BILL LEGISLATION REQUIRING C.
COST TO REPORT ANNUALLY TO THE
LEGISLATURE BEGINNING JULY ONE
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO ON
RELEVANT DATA- CONCERNING
TRAINING OUTCOMES AND
CONCLUSIONS IT DRAWS FROM THE
DATA AS WELL AS- PLANS TO
ADDRESS ANY. CHALLENGES OR
CONCERNS THAT ARE IDENTIFIED.
THE SECOND COMPONENT APPROACH
OF THE PROPOSAL IS THE NEW
FACILITY FOR HANDS ON TRAINING
THAT WOULD BE INTEGRATED INTO
THE EXISTING ACADEMY FOR
TRAINING NEW CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS AND WE THINK THAT
THIS- APPEARS WORTHWHILE TO
INSURING JEFF- THAT NEW
OFFICERS ARRIVE AT THEIR POSTS-
WELL PREPARED SO WE DO
RECOMMEND APPROVING IT. THE
THIRD COMPONENT IS THE NEW JOB
SHADOWING PROGRAM FOR OFFICERS
AFTER THEY GRADUATE FROM THE
CAN THE ACADEMY IN WHEN THEY
ARRIVE AT THE PRISON WHERE
WHERE THEY'LL BE WORKING.
SIMILARLY TO THE HANDS ON
TRAINING FACILITY WE THINK THAT
THE GENERAL IDEA OF THIS ASPECT
OF THE PROPOSAL MAKES SENSE BUT
WE DO HAVE CONCERNS WITH THAT
SPECIFIC RESOURCES REQUESTED TO
SUPPORT IT- I WAS ALREADY
DISCUSSED WE HAVE CONCERNS WITH
THE THIRTY THREE STARTING
POSITIONS SO I'LL JUST BE
BRIEF- SEVENTEEN OF THE
POSITIONS ARE RELATED TO THE-
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH THE
NEW JOB. SHADOWING PROGRAM BUT
THE REMAINING SIXTEEN ARE
DRIVEN BY IT AN INTENTION TO
RELIEVE EXISTING STAFF. OF
CERTAIN DUTIES SO THAT THEY CAN
FOCUS ON OTHER WORK THAT'S THE
DEPARTMENT REPORT ISN'T GETTING
DONE IN A TIMELY MANNER. AND
THE DEPARTMENT HASN'T BEEN ABLE
TO. RIGHT ADEQUATE INFORMATION
TO JUSTIFY THE NEEDS FOR THOSE
SEVENTEEN POSITIONS- SO WE
WOULD EXPECT FOR EXAMPLE THE
DEPARTMENT TO PROVIDE DATA
DEMONSTRATING THE EXTENT TO
WHICH WORKLOAD IS DELAYED AND-
A DETAILED ANALYSIS OF HOW MANY
POSITIONS WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
GET THAT WORK. DONE IN A TIMELY
MANNER. SO WE RECOMMEND
REJECTING THE SEVENTEEN
POSITIONS. AND ASSOCIATED TWO
POINT SEVEN MILLION IN ANNUAL
FUNDING. THE SECOND A RESOURCE
FOR THE JOB SHADOWING PROGRAM
THAT WE HAVE CONCERNS WITH IS
THE SIX POINT TWO MILLION TO
PAY THE NEW OFFICERS WHILE
THEY'RE ARTICIPATING IN THE
THREE WEEKS OF JOB SHADOWING.
AND NOT BECAUSE THAT NUMBER IS
BASED OFF AN ASSUMPTION THAT
CDCR WILL HAVE A ONE THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
OFFICERS GOINGTHROUGH THE JOB
SHATTERING PROGRAM ANNUALLY BUT
AFTER DEVELOPING THE BCP THE
DEPARTMENT ASTON'S REVISED
THEIR ESTIMATE ON THE NUMBER OF
OFFICERS IT EXPECTS TO PRODUCE
IN THE BUDGET YEAR 210-004-0060
SIX. SO WE RECOMMEND REDUCING
THE FUNDING BY ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION TO ACCOUNT FOR THIS-
FEWER NUMBER OF OFFICERS THAT
ARE EXPECTED TO GO THROUGH THE
JOB SHADOWING PROGRAM IN THE
BUDGET YEAR. AND THEN THE MY
FINAL COMMENT IS AN OVERARCHING
ONE- AND THAT IS THAT PRISON
CLOSURES WILL REDUCE THE NEED
FOR NEW OFFICERS IN THE FUTURE-
IN THE YEARS WHEN. AROUND WHEN
THE PRISONS ARE CLOSED. AND
THAT'S BECAUSE WHEN A PRISON IS
CLOSED OFFICERS OUT THERE
PRISON HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
MOVE. TO FILL VACANCIES AT
OTHER PRISONS WHICH THEN
REDUCES THE NEED FOR CDC ARE
TO. PRODUCE NEW OFFICERS THERE
IT'S ACADEMY TO. FILL THOSE
VACANCIES. SO IN TYPICAL PEOPLE
ARE PAST YEARS- CCAR'S- NEED
FOR NEW OFFICERS IS RELATIVELY
CONSISTENT FROM YEAR TO YEAR
AND SO IT'S BUDGET IS AN
ADJUSTED ANNUALLY BASED ON A
CHANGE IN THE NEED FOR NEW
OFFICERS BUT GIVEN THE
ANTICIPATED PRISON CLOSURES WE
THINK THAT THE EXISTING BASE
FUNDING AS WELL AS THE OUT YOUR
COMPONENTS OF FOR CERTAIN
ELEMENTS OF THE ARE YOUR
COMPONENTS- THAT ARE BEING
PROPOSED. HERE TODAY SUCH AS
THAT FUNDING FOR NEW OFFICERS
GOING THROUGH THE JOB SHADOWING
PROGRAM. WILL BECOME EXCESSIVE
SO WE RECOMMEND PASSING BUDGET
TRAILER LEGISLATION REQUIRING
THE ADMINISTRATION TO PROPOSE
ADJUSTMENTS TO CDC ARTS BUDGET
FOR TRAINING NEW CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS. ON AN ANNUAL BASIS-
THIS WOULD BE SIMILAR TO THE
WAY THAT CDC ARE ALREADY
ADDRESS OTHER AREAS OF ITS
BUDGET. IN RESPONSE ANNUALLY-
BASED ON CHANGES IN VARIOUS
CASELOADS OR OTHER FACTORS SUCH
AS THE NUMBER OF INMATES ARE
PAROLEES. THANK YOU GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY NORTH
QUESTIONS COLLEAGUES OKAY SO-
WE'RE GONNA HOLD THAT OPEN AND
MOVE ON NOW- TO ISSUE FIVE AND
THIS IS DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
WE ARE WE ARE YOU ARE YOU OKAY
WITH A TOPPING AND IN A AND FOR
A FEW COMMENTS IN RESPONSE TO
THAT LEO. APOLOGIZE FOR ACTING
NO I APOLOGIZE I DROP YOU CAN.
BOOK YOUR NAME OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE WITH. THANK YOU THANK
YOU COARSELY MATT APART OF
SCIENCE. AT YOU. SO WE WOULD
LIKE TO RESPOND TO THE L.
RECOMMENDATIONS- WE OPPOSE THE
ADDITION OF ANY TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO
CONTINUE THE DISCUSSION- WE'RE
NOT CONVINCED THAT TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE IS NECESSARY BUT WE
RESPECT THE LEGISLATURE'S
DESIRE FOR ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION. AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
EXPLORE WHAT'S- AVAILABLE AND
REASONABLE AS WELL AS ANY
POTENTIAL. FISCAL IMPACT OF
WHAT THAT MIGHT RESULT IN. IN
RESPONSE TO THE JOB SHADOWING
THE SIXTEEN OR SEVENTEEN
SERGEANTS. WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE A SERGEANT AT
EACH INSTITUTION DEDICATED TO
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE JOB
SHADOWING PROGRAM EACH
INSTITUTION HAS A DIFFERENT
LAYOUT MISSION. INMATE
POPULATION AND ITS OWN UNIQUE
ATTRIBUTES SO WE THINK IT'S
CRITICAL FOR STAFF WHO OVERSEE
THE JOB SHADOWING PROGRAM TO
REALLY BE WELL VERSED IN THE
SPECIFICS OF THEIR INSTITUTION
SO THAT NEW CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS REALLY RECEIVED THEIR
SITE SPECIFIC. TRAINING AND
THEY'LL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
WORKING WITH THE STAFF TO
ENSURE THAT THE TRAINING IS
EFFECTIVE INFORMATIVE AND
REALLY MAXIMIZES THE LEARNING
EXPERIENCE THERE. IN RESPONSE
TO THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE-
FOR ADJUSTMENTS TO THE ACADEMY
WE THINK IT'S PREMATURE TO
CONSIDERADJUSTING THE OVERALL
ECONOMY RESOURCES THERE'S AND
NUMEROUS UNKNOWNS IN THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE WHICH MAKES
IT DIFFICULT TO ESTIMATE THAT
CORRECTIONAL OFFICER IN THE
LONG TERM. THE ATTRITION RATE
ITSELF IS BASED ON A NUMBER OF
FACTORS THERE'S BEEN ADDITIONAL
RETIREMENTS DUE TO COAL FED-
SALARY CHANGES AFFECT ATTRITION
AND JUST THE EFFECTS OF PRISON
PRISON CLOSURE IN THE FUTURE AS
WELL. SO EVEN IF THERE'S A
REDUCING IN THE SHORT TERM
THOUGH WILL BE CONTINUED
RETIREMENTS WHICH WILL NEED TO
BE BACK FELT. SO WE STILL NEED
THE ECONOMY INFRASTRUCTURE IN
PLACE AS THE DEPARTMENT NEEDS
TO BE READY FOR A LONGER TERM
CHANGES TO THEIR WORKFORCE.
HOWEVER WE WOULD CONSIDER
CONSOLIDATION WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE. BUT IT'S STILL
PREMATURE NOW. THANK YOU OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY DID I
GET EVERYBODY HERE OKAY. ALL
RIGHT ISSUE FIVE- TECHNOLOGY
FOR INMATES PARTICIPATING IN
ACADEMIC PROGRAMS MISTER
SWANSON I BELIEVE YOU'RE GONNA
PRESENT. THAT'S RIGHT ISSUE
FIVE- IS AN ISSUE WE ARE REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT IS AN APARTMENT
YOUR REQUEST TWENTY THREE POINT
TWO MILLION GENERAL FUND. AND
FORTY THREE POSITIONS IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
IN SMALLER AMOUNTS IN FUTURE
YEARS. DEPLOYED APPROXIMATELY
THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND DIDN'T
CLIENT LAPTOPS FOR INMATES TO
ENHANCE THEIR EDUCATION
PROGRAMS AND CREATE A CLOUD
NETWORK- REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS SUPPORT. HERE TO TALK
ABOUT THIS ISSUE- CHERYL LARSON
WHO IS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
THE DIVISION OF REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS. AND WAYNE BADDIE WHO
IS THE CHIEF. OF ENTERPRISE
INFORMATION SYSTEMS WE'RE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. BOB SO
IT'S UP TO US. ALL RIGHT I WAS
GONNA GET A PRESENTATION. OKAY
ALL RIGHT I DO HAVE QUESTIONS-
I THINK IT'S- I THINK IT'S ON
THE ONE HAND THE REALLY. GREAT
THING TO HAVE- THE USE OF
LAPTOPS FROM FOR LEARNING- BUT
I HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS WITH
THAT RICK WITH REGARDS TO THAT-
HOW DO YOU GET THE COMBINED-
TECHNOLOGY- TRAINING ALL. AND
NOT DROP THE FACE TO FACE- OF
COURSES AND LEARNING THAT'S
ALSO REALLY IMPORTANT AS WE SEE
NOW WE'RE GOING THROUGH THIS
COALBED AND THE OUR KIDS AND
EVERYBODY'S ANXIOUS FOR THE
KIDS TO GET BACK TO SCHOOL BUT
YOU TO HAVE THE FACE TO FACE-
AND NOT JUST ALL OVER A LAPTOP
OVER A COMPUTER. I SUSPECT THAT
THE A SIMILAR THING SO HOW WILL
YOU DO I WILL YOU DO BOTH OR
AND HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT
THIS DOESN'T REPLACE OF THE
FACE TO FACE ODD TRAINING AND
LEARNING AND AN EDUCATION THERE
ARE THAT'S ONE- A WILL ONLINE
COURSES BE. LITERACY BASED ARM
OF THAT'S ANOTHER ONE AND- I'M
CURIOUS IF YOU CAN EXPLAIN MORE
ABOUT HOW THE LAPTOPS PROGRAM
AND THE MC THREE. SKILL
DEVELOPMENTS ALL WILL WORK
TOGETHER SEOUL. WHO CAN ANSWER
THOSE. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MY NAME IS SARAH LARSON I AM
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
DIVISION OF REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS AT CDC I THINK I CAN
HANDLE ALL OF THOSE QUESTIONS
CAN YOU HEAR ME OK BEFORE I GET
STARTED PERFECT THANK YOU YES
GREAT THANK YOU. SO TO START
WITH YOUR QUESTION ABOUT FACE
TO FACE PROGRAMMING AND WHETHER
THIS IS A KIND OF A SUPPLEMENT
FOR A REPLACEMENT FOR FACE TO
FACE WE ABSOLUTELY THINK
THERE'S NO SUBSTITUTE FOR FACE
TO FACE INSTRUCTION I THINK OF
IT AS YOU MENTIONED AS AN
EXCELLENT EXAMPLE FOR WHY THAT
IS AND THIS IS REALLY JUST
MEANT TO SUPPORT A FACE TO FACE
INSTRUCTION THAT WE HAVE. WITH
OUR TEACHERS IN OUR CLASSROOMS.
A GOOD WAY TO THINK ABOUT
SERIOUSLY OUR EDUCATION IS LIKE
A ONE ROOM SCHOOLHOUSE. WE HAVE
FOLKS WHO ARE. YOU KNOW
BUILDING EARLY AS YOU MENTIONED
LITERACY SKILLS. AND WE ALSO
HAVE STUDENTS WHO ARE LOOKING
TOWARDS A GED OR HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA POTENTIALLY THINKING
ABOUT. I'M PURSUING A COLLEGE
EDUCATION OF SOME KIND. AND
THEY'RE THEY'RE LEARNING KIND
OF IT AT DIFFERENT LEVELS. AND
EVEN WITH A IN A CLASSROOM AND
EVEN FOR STUDENTS WORK AND ACT
THE SAME. LEARNING LEVEL
THEY'RE GOING TO PROGRESS
THROUGH DIFFERENT ON. MODULES
OF LEARNING DIFFERENTLY. SO FOR
EXAMPLE I MIGHT. EXCEL AT
GEOMETRY BUT STRUGGLE WITH
ALGEBRA AND ANOTHER STUDENT
MIGHT. BE REALLY GOOD WITH-
ALGEBRA BUT REALLY STRUGGLE
WITH GEOMETRY. WITH THE LAPTOPS
WOULD DO IS IN THE CLASSROOM
ENVIRONMENT. ALLOW FOR OUR
TEACHERS TO PROVIDE TARGETED
INSTRUCTION TO THOSE STUDENTS.
OVER WHEN MOST OF THE CLASSROOM
IS KIND OF READY TO MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT LASSEN. BUT A STUDENT
IS FEELING LIKE MAYBE. THEY
NEED A LITTLE BIT MORE PRACTICE.
A TEACHER WOULD BE ABLE TO FIND
THE ADDITION PROBLEM THAT COULD
HAVE BEEN HEROES TOLD TO HELP
THEM. AND NOT IN THE CLASSROOM
WHERE THE TEACHER COULD BE
PROVIDING THEM WITH SUPPORT AND
FEEDBACK THINK OF IT KIND OF
LIKE A BREAKOUT GROUPS. AND TO
ALLOW FOR TARGETED INSTRUCTION
AND RIGHT NOW WITHOUT THOSE
DEVICES WE DON'T REALLY HAVE
THAT. ABILITY TO DO THAT KIND
OF TARGETED INSTRUCTION IN THE
SAME WAY. THIS WOULD DEFINITELY
SUPPORT OUR NEEDS IN THE
CLASSROOM HEY AND THEN THE
OTHER BIG BENEFIT IS THAT WOULD
ALLOW STUDENTS TO CONTINUE
THEIR LEARNING OUTSIDE OF THE
CLASSROOM. BUT WE CAN ASSIGN
ADDITIONAL PROBLEMS OR OR
VIDEOS TO WATCH. SOMETHING YOU
CAN KIND OF FEEL LIKE HOMEWORK
OR ADDITIONAL PRACTICE PROBLEMS
THAT YOU MIGHT GET AND THE
COMMUNITY SCHOOL AND THAT WOULD
ALLOW STUDENTS SUPPORT THE
INSTRUCTION THAT THEY'RE
SEEING. FACE TO FACE AND ALLOW
THEM TO CONTINUE TO PRACTICE
KIND OF IN THEIR FREE TIME AND
WHERE THEY MIGHT WANT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK THROUGH. THEIR
VARIOUS ASSIGNMENTS AND KIND OF
CONTINUE BUT BANDS WE THINK
THAT'LL REALLY HELP OUR
STUDENTS. AND I THINK THE OTHER
THING TO THINK ABOUT TOO IS.
FOR STUDENTS IN FEWEST YARDS
THERE'S A HUGE DIGITAL DIVIDE
RIGHT NOW. THEY DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO THE TYPE OF
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S REALLY
REQUIRED. FOR PROFESSIONAL WORK
WHEN STATE RETURN TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES WITHIN THE LAPTOPS
WILL REALLY HELP THEM TO BUILD
THOSE SKILLS THAT THEY'LL NEED
TO BE SUCCESSFUL ONCE. THEY
RETURNED TO THE COMMUNITY. I
HOPE THAT ANSWERS THAT
PARTICULAR. IF NOT I'M HAPPY
TO. COME BACK TO IT- WHEN YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT LITERACY. THIS
PROPOSAL WILL PROVIDE DEVICES
TO ALL OF THE STUDENTS AND OUR
DEAR PEOPLE AROUND SO THAT
INCLUDES FOLKS WHO ARE WORKING
ON THEIR LITERACY. AND WHO ARE
WORKING ON HIGH SCHOOL
EDUCATION STUDENTS WHO ARE
PURSUING. A COLLEGE EDUCATION.
TO OUR STUDENTS WHO ARE
PURSUING A CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION OR PARTICIPATING IN
OUR COGNITIVE BEHAVIORAL.
INTERVENTIONS AND SO IT REALLY
WILL SUPPORT A WIDE VARIETY OF
STUDENTS INCLUDING THOSE
STUDENTS WHO. ARE WORKING ON
THEIR LITERACY SKILLS. I IN THE
LAST- SORRY GO HEAD NO NO NO
THANK. IF YOU FINISH. SO THE
LAST QUESTION THAT YOU HAD
ASKED WAS ABOUT. KIND OF THE
CERTIFICATION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONAL SKILLS I KNOW YOU
MENTIONED AND SEE THREE IN
PARTICULAR SO AS I MENTIONED
THESE WILL SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS
WHO ARE PURSUING CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION. THE WE DO
HAVE A VARIETY OF AND WHAT WE
CALL CTA CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS THAT INCLUDE
A INDUSTRY STANDARD
CERTIFICATIONS INCLUDING NANCY
THREE AND THERE ARE ALSO OTHERS
JUST DEPENDING KIND OF ON THAT
PARTICULAR ASKING YOU PROGRAM
THAT EXIST. AND SO THESE
DEVICES WILL BE USED TO SUPPORT
STUDENTS IN THOSE PROGRAMS SO
THE WAY I THINK I KIND OF THINK
ABOUT THESE DEVICES WHEN IT
COMES TO CP IS. WILL USE.
WHATEVER TOOL IS NECESSARY FOR
PROFESSIONAL TRAINING SO THAT
MAYBE A HAMMER IN SOME
CIRCUMSTANCES IF YOU'RE AND YOU
KNOW LEARNING SOME TRADE SKILLS
AND IT MAY ALSO BE A MODULE
THAT YOU'RE LEARNING ON A
COMPUTER OR YOUR LEARNING CAD
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT. ON THE
DEVICE THE KIND OF BUILD YOUR
PROFESSIONAL SKILLS AND SO
WE'LL MAKE THOSE MODULES
AVAILABLE IN OUR LEARNING
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM I THINK IT'LL
BE REALLY GREAT FOR OUR
STUDENTS BECAUSE THEY'LL HAVE
MORE OPPORTUNITY AND MORE TIME
TO BUILD THOSE SKILLS AND- KIND
OF CONTINUE THEIR LEARNING
OUTSIDE OF JUST THE NORMAL
CLASSROOM TIME THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE. BUT THEY'LL HAVE
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITY TO KIND
OF REVIEW AND- CAN TAKE
MATERIAL IN INK AND PRACTICE
WITH THAT- EAT. IN THE
CLASSROOM AND ALSO OUTSIDE.
OKAY GREAT JUST WHAT SMALL
COSTA- CANNING CA OF PEOPLE
TAKE THEIR CIVIL SERVICE EXAMS
WITH THESE LAPTOPS. WE'LL BE
WORKING ON AND IT IT REALLY
DEPENDS ON KIND OF HOW WE CAN
INCORPORATE THOSE SYSTEMS IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN MAKE
AVAILABLE TO FOLKS WILL HAVE TO
WORK WITH INDIVIDUAL SYSTEMS I
THINK TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO MAKE
IT ACCESSIBLE AND HONOR
LEARNING MANAGEMENT PLATFORMS
BUT JUST AS- EVERYONE IS AWARE
WE ALSO HAVE CURRENTLY UP WHAT
WE CALL OUR ARCADE SYSTEM. AND
THAT PROVIDES ALL SORTS OF
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITY INFORMATION FOR AT
OUR STUDENTS AS THEY'RE GETTING
RELEASED AND THAT INCLUDES REAL
TIME JOB INFORMATION THAT WE
HAVE AVAILABLE ON THE SYSTEM
AND THAT WILL BE AVAILABLE ON
THESE DEVICES AND THAT INCLUDES
NOT JUST CIVIL SERVICE BUT ALSO
ALSO. A PRIVATE EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THEY MIGHT
BE ABLE TO PURSUE IN THE
COMMUNITY WHERE THEY'RE NOT
BEING RETURNED OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- COLLEAGUES. ANY
COUPLE YES CENTER NEWMAN. THANK
YOU THANK YOU AFTER THE A
COUPLE OF COURSE TO ARM. THIS
BEING INFORMATION THAT THE
SEVENTH- THIN CLIENT LAPTOPS
OUT OF CURIOSITY WHY THAT
NUMBER Y. THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND.
AND HOW YOU HOW DID YOU ARRIVE
AT THE- SURE ABSOLUTELY I CAN
ANSWER THAT QUESTION I THINK.
SO THE THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND
ROUGHLY REPRESENTS THE NUMBER
OF STUDENTS THAT WE HAD IN OUR
PROGRAMS RIGHT NOW SO AS I
MENTIONED THAT'S ALL OF OUR
DEAR PIEPER GAMS ACADEMIC
EDUCATION AND CAREER TECHNICAL
AND COGNITIVE BEHAVIORAL
INTERVENTIONS. AND WE REDUCE
THE NUMBER SLIGHTLY FROM THE
OVERALL NUMBER OF PARTICIPANTS
JUST TO REFLECT THAT YOU KNOW
FOLKS ARE IN TRANSIT OR MIGHT
BE OUT TO CORD OR A MEDICAL
APPOINTMENT OR THINGS LIKE
THAT. WE THINK THIS REPRESENTS
THE NUMBER OF DEVICES THAT WILL
NEED TO HAVE AVAILABLE I'M SURE
THAT ALL OF OUR STUDENTS HAVE
THE ABILITY TO ACCESS ONE WHEN
THEY NEED IT. AND CAN YOU
WITHIN THE NUMBER CAN YOU CAN
YOU WILL YOU ARE CAN YOU
PRIORITIZE AGAINST. DIFFERENT
KINDS OF EDUCATION SO MY
INSURANCE IS ABOUT TEN
THOUSAND. INMATES RIGHT NOW WHO
ENGAGE IN POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION WILL THEY RECEIVE
PRIORITY OR OR IS THERE A
MATRIX FOR THAT SORT OF-
DETERMINATION. WE DO HAVE A-
FOR OUR ROLLING OUT THE
DEVICES- PRIMARILY THAT'S BASED
ON EACH. INDIVIDUAL LOCATION
EACH INSTITUTION RATHER THAN
INDIVIDUAL PROGRAMS ARE BEING
PRIORITIZED I JUST AS WE BUILD
OUT THAT THE TECHNOLOGY IN THE
NETWORK AND I CAN PROVIDE THAT.
I TEAR STAFF SO THAT YOU HAVE
THAT AVAILABLE. SHOULD THAT SO
THE CHARITY TOUCHED ON. THE KEY
QUESTIONS FACE TO FACE
EDUCATION WHICH IS CLEARLY- OF
SIGNIFICANT VALUE- YOU KNOW
BOTH FOR THE QUALITY EDUCATION
BUT ALSO FOR- SOME OTHER SOFT
SKILLS THAT ARE INCULCATED
DURING THAT. MISTER CLEARLY
DURING COLD GOOD- WE FACE SOME
CHALLENGES BUT MOVING FORWARD.
THERE IS SOME CONCEN. AMONG
ADVOCATES IN PICTURESQUE SOCIAL
PROGRAMS THAT- THAT WILL STAY
IN THE ONLINE LEARNING. SPACE
AND NOT NATIONALLY RETURNED TO
EITHER FACE TO FACE PROGRAMS OR
PROJECTS IMPORTANTLY. RESPECT
CONTINUE THOSE RELATIONSHIPS
WITH PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES THE
COMMITTEE COLLEGES. AND STATE
COLLEGES. SO WHAT INSURANCE IS
THAT AS WE MOVE FORWARD THAT
THAT WE THESE. PROGRAMS WON'T
BE DISPLACED OR COMPETE WITH
FOR PROFIT. ONLINE EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES. YEAH THAT'S IT
THE NEXT QUESTION SO RIGHT NOW
ALL THE PROGRAMS THAT WE
PARTNER WITH IN OUR
INSTITUTIONS- OR THAT- WE WORK
WITH KIND OF. AND THREE D. R.
P. ARE ACCREDITED NONPROFIT
INSTITUTIONS WE DO ALLOW
STUDENTS TO PURSUE THE
EDUCATION OUT THERE THEY WANT
TO PURSUE AND IF THEY'RE READY
FOR POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
AND- THEIR INDIVIDUAL DESIRE IS
TO PURSUE. A DEGREE KIND OF
PRIVATELY. THERE ARE ABLE TO DO
THAT BUT THE VAST VAST MAJORITY
OF OUR STUDENTS ARE RECEIVING
THEIR COLLEGE EDUCATION
THROUGH. THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AT MANY OF THEM ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR AND THAT PROMISE GRANT
FUNDING WHICH ALLOWS THEM TO
PURSUE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DEGREES AT NO COST FOR THEM.
AND THAT'S THE VAST VAST
MAJORITY OF OUR POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION STUDENTS AND HOW
THEY'RE GETTING EDUCATION WE
ALSO HAVE A SMALL NUMBER OF A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE STUDENTS. WHO
HAVE BEEN PURSUING I FACE TO
FACE RIGHT NOW IT'S AND YOU
KNOW MORE CORRESPONDENCE BASED
BECAUSE OF COVERAGE BUT- WHO
HAVE BEEN PERSON FACE TO FACE
EDUCATION WITH OUR- CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. AND WE
HAVE A FEW LOCATIONS WHERE
WE'RE DOING THAT AND I'D BE
HAPPY TO PROVIDE KIND OF A LIST
OF THOSE. LOCATIONS ARE BREAK
OUT KIND OF WHAT THAT
PARTICIPATION. LOOKS LIKE BUT
IT IS. VERY HEAVILY AND IN THE-
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY JUST. AND
THEN- ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY WITH
ACCREDITED NONPROFIT SCHOOLS
JUDICIARY AND THAT'S
ENCOURAGING BUT WE WON REGION
BERMAN- IS CONGRESS RECENT
LIFTED THE BAN ON PELL GRANTS
FOR INCARCERATED STUDENTS- AND
SO THAT THAT. IN THE AGGREGATE
REPRESENTS A LOT OF MONEY- AND
SO DO WE HAVE YOUR ASSURANCE
THAT WILL. PROTECT THOSE FUNDS
I GUESS THOSE STUDENTS. FROM
MARKETING AND ENROLLMENT IN FOR
PROFIT EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES IT MAY NOT NOT BE
NEARLY AS EFFICIENT AND NOT
NEARLY AS GOOD AS THE ONES THEY
CURRENTLY UTILIZE. ALSO THE
WALGREENS CHANGE HAS BEEN A
VERY RECENT AND WON'T BE
IMPLEMENTED FOR SOME TIME AND
SO WE'RE STILL WORKING THROUGH
THE- DETAILS OF HOW THAT WILL
WORK AND SO I DON'T HAVE ANY
INFORMATION YET ON HOW THAT
WILL BE IMPLEMENTED IT'S
SOMETHING THAT. WE'RE IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ON CURRENTLY AND AS WELL AS YOU
KNOW MANY FOLKS WHO ARE WHO ARE
INTERESTED IN GETTING OUR
STUDENTS ACCESS TO A COLLEGE
EDUCATION. BUT I CAN ASSURE YOU
THAT THAT CURRENTLY THOSE ARE
NOT THAT PULLS THAT WE PROVIDE
PROGRAMMING FOR AND OUR
INSTITUTIONS. BRIGITTA THANK
YOU FOR THANK YOU. SENATOR
CORTEZ. THE COMMAND CHAIR- CAN
YOU CAN YOU EDUCATE ME A LITTLE
BIT ON THE DOES NEED A WIRELESS
AREAS AND- HOW THAT WORKS I
KNOW THE NEXT TIME WE GET INTO
CELLULAR INTERDICTION- BUT THAT
REALLY SPEAKS SPECIFICALLY TO
CELLULAR I'M JUST WONDERING
WHAT SAFEGUARDS. ARE IN PLACE-
IF THOSE CURRENTLY EXIST OR IF
MORE. WILL BE NEEDED- FOR THIS
PROGRAM. I THINK THIS QUESTION
I'LL DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUE
WHILE NGUYEN BADDIE WHO HAS
EXPERTISE IN OUR INFORMATION
SYSTEMS AT BECAUSE I THINK HIS
ANSWER PROBABLY I'M NOT WILL
WILL BE THE MOST- I'LL- THANK
YOU. I APOLOGIZE WHEN BADLY CVC
ARE SELDOM SENATOR DANCE YOUR
QUESTION- WE HAVE WIRELESS IN
OUR CLASSROOMS CURRENTLY- WE DO
HAVE ACCESS AND ARE LIVING
AREAS- PART OF OUR STRATEGY
THOUGH IS TO REALLY HAVE
SECURITY AROUND BOTH ACCESS AT
THE NETWORK LEVEL USER SECURITY
APPLICATION WEEK WE HAVE A
PRETTY WELL THOUGHT OUT PLAN.
ON HOW TO SECURE TO MAKE SURE
THAT- WE DON'T GRAB ANY ILLICIT
ACCESS TO DEVICES. YEAH RIGHT
OBVIOUSLY I DON'T NEED YOU TO
DISCLOSE HOW ALL THAT WORKS YOU
KNOW IN A IN A PUBLIC SETTING-
BUT WHAT WHAT IS THE REVIEW
PROCESS FOR IT TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT IS WORKING ERIC I GUESS
THAT'S WHAT I REALLY WANT TO
KNOW- IT SOUNDS LIKE THAT'S-
THAT'S LARGELY. PART OF WHAT
YOU'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR BUT-
OBVIOUSLY IF WE WERE DEALING
WITH- WITH FINANCES OR OF OR
OTHER- GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS WE
WOULD HAVE SOME SORT OF AN
AUDIT PROCESS IN THE REVIEW
PROCESS- AGAIN I DON'T WANT TO
JUMP AHEAD I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT'S TIED TO. THE
INTERDICTION PROGRAM OR IF IT'S
JUST SOMETHING IS DONE
SEPARATELY FOR THIS PROGRAM.
BUT SENATOR WHEN BABBY AGAIN I
CAN TELL YOU THAT- SECURITY FOR
THIS PROPOSAL WAS OUR NUMBER%
ONE PRIORITY- SO THERE'S
pDIFFERENT LEVELS WITHOUT
GETTING TOO MUCH INTO THE INTO
THE WEEDS- THERE'S DIFFERENT
LEVELS WERE GONNA HANDLE
SECURITY OUT- WE DO HAVE AN
INFORMATION SECURITY OFFICE WE-
HAVE A- PRETTY ROBUST SECURITY
PLATFORM- SO I CAN ASSURE YOU
THAT SENSE OF THE TOP OF OUR
MINDS WITH THIS PROPOSAL. IT IS
IT THE LET ME JUST ASK THIS
MUCH DOES DOES IT INVOLVED
ACTUAL REAL TIME MONITORING OF.
THE SO WITHOUT THEM. WITHOUT
GETTING TOO MUCH INTO IT- IT
INVOLVES HAVING AN ENVIRONMENT
THAT CENTRAL SO WE CAN CONTROL
EVERYTHING THAT'S ON THE
ENVIRONMENT WE CAN CONTROL
ACCESS TO IT ACCESS OUT OF IT
IN A DOES ALLOW US TO LOG
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THEIR TO
ALERT ON CERTAIN EVENTS. IT
ISN'T. JUST A JUST A FOR
FUTURE. FOR FUTURE REFERENCE
QUESTION- EFFECT IS THAT IS THE
SYSTEM. INTERNALLY AND
CONFIDENTIALLY SERVICEABLE BY
ACCESSIBLE COLLECTED OFFICIALS
WHO WANT TO COME IN- AND
UNDERSTAND IT IN A NON PUBLIC
SETTING- WHAT THE SECURITY
MEASURES ARE. I THINK IF
THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION WOULD BE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH YOUR STAFF- TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN YEAH I DON'T I'D
LIKE TO COME IN AND- IT JUST-
I'M A VISUAL PERSON LET'S PUT
IT THAT WAY COMMENSALISM TIME
OBVIOUSLY IN A CONFIDENTIAL
MANNER. THANK YOU MANAGER.
GREAT FROM THERE WE DO FINANCE.
L. A. L. MISLEADING. YOU DON'T
HAVE ANY I'M SORRY. ARAMBULA
PERSPECTIVE THANK YOU OKAY
GREAT THAT COLLEAGUES YEAH OKAY
WONDERFUL ALL RIGHT. THERE ARE
OTHER ANTI FRIENDS WHAT
APARTMENT FINANCED BY OKAY YES
PLEASE JUST WANTED OUT IN- NO
FURTHER COMMENT FROM FINANCE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU- LET'S SEE WE'RE ON NUMBER
FIVE. YES OKAY WE'LL MOVE ON TO
ISSUE FIVE- TECHNOLOGY FOR
INMATES ON ON ARNOLD ROUND.
SORRY WHERE I JUST HAD ONE MORE
I'M SORRY JUST ONE FINAL
QUESTION- HOW MANY- STUDENTS
ARE ENROLLED IN PRIVATE
INSTITUTION COURSES AND THAT
WHICHINSTITUTIONS. AND THEN
WE'LL MOVE ON. CLARIFY ARE YOU
ASKING ABOUT LIKE A PRIVATE
COLLEGE COURSE YES. I CAN
PROVIDE THOSE NUMBERS TEARS
HERE STAFF AS A FOLLOW UP WITH
THE BEST SPECIFIC NUMBERS OKAY
AND THEN WHICH INSTITUTIONS YES
OKAY ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YEAH ALL RIGHT LET'S MOVE
ON NOW WE CAN TO ISSUE SIX
CELLULAR INTRODUCTION PROGRAM
MISTER SWANSON. YES IF YOU SIX
IS A REQUEST FOR ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY
TWO AND I'M GOING TO MAINTAIN
THE EXISTING MANAGED ACCESS
SYSTEM. AND EIGHTEEN
INSTITUTIONS THIS SYSTEM AS WE
DISCUSSED A LITTLE BIT EARLIER
THE LAST ISSUE PREVENTS
UNAUTHORIZED CELLPHONE USE. IN
THE INSTITUTION. WITH ME ON
THIS ISSUE ARE ASSOCIATE WARDEN
MERION SPEARMAN AND TAMMY IRWIN
WHO IS THE CHIEF OF ENTERPRISE
INFORMATION SYSTEM. SERVICES
AND I THINK WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH HIM IF WE COULD JUST
TO TALK ABOUT THE NEED FOR THIS
REQUEST. IRWIN CAN YOU HEAR ME
OK YES GO AHEAD. IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE THE DEPARTMENT
WORKED WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY AND TO INITIATE A
CONTRACT FOR INMATE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS AND IT
INCLUDED MANAGED ACCESS. WHICH
IS THE CELLULAR INTERDICTION-
TECHNOLOGY THAT HELPS US TO
CONTROL UNAUTHORISED ACCESS TO
AND BY THE USE OF CONTRABAND
DEVICES. SO IN IT WAS INITIALLY
PLANNED TO DEPLOY AND MANAGE
ACCESS TO ALL OF THE
DEPARTMENTS AND INSTITUTIONS
BUT IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN IT
WAS DECIDED- TO REFOCUS ON THAT
INTENTION AND REDIRECT- BE
CONCENTRATION NOT ON THE
DEVICES THAT IT ALREADY MADE IT
FOUND ITS WAY INTO THE PRISON
ENVIRONMENT BUT TO- TRY TO.
PRETEND TO BE INTRODUCTION-
CONTRABAND AND DEVICES ARE
BEFORE THEY ENTERED INTO THAT
THE PRESENT. SEVEN TWO SIXTEEN
IT WAS RENEGOTIATED TO- STOP
THE EXPANSION OF MANAGE ACCESS
AND TO BRING IN OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES LIKE EXTRA
BAGGAGE- AND PARCEL SCANNERS
LOW DOES FULL BODY SCANNERS-
METAL DETECTORS I'LL WALK
THROUGH METAL DETECTORS AND
METAL DETECTORS. SO I'M THAT'S
THE REASON WHY WE HAVE MANAGED
ACCESS EIGHTEEN INSTITUTIONS.
BERMAN JUST RECENTLY-
NEGOTIATED A CONTRACT FOR
INMATE COMMUNICATIONS AND IT
WAS- AND IT DOES NOT INCLUDE
MANAGED ACCESS. THOSE FOCUSES
JUST ON THE CAN YOUR
COMMUNICATIONS AND SEARCH THE
TECHNOLOGY- TO INTERJECT AND
TO- CONTROL CELLULAR
CONNECTIVITY FROM COUNTRYMEN
DEVICES. IS NOW GOING TO BE A
SEPARATE CONTRACT WITH THE
APPROVAL OF THIS PROPOSAL AND
HOW WE WOULD ASK YOU SEE OUR
WILL MANAGE THE AB MANAGE.
ACCESS AND SERVICE PROVIDER.
I'M AND KEEP THE AS- RUNNING
AND OPTIMIZED ASK THE EIGHTEEN
INSTITUTIONS WHERE IT EXISTS.
OKAY RIGHT- THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OUR VALET- HAVE ANY COMMENTS.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH
THE PROPOSED SANCTIONING YES.
THAT SPECIFIC PROPOSAL BEFORE
YOU- BUT IN THE COURSE OF
REVIEWING IT WE DID LEARN THAT
AS WAS MENTIONED THE DEPARTMENT
HAS RENEGOTIATED ITS CONTRACT
FOR PROVIDING- INMATES IN THE
WORDS OF TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SERVICES AND SO WHEN THE
DETAILS OF THAT CONTRACT I SUCH
AS A PRICE OF PHONE CALLS
BECOME AVAILABLE WE WILL TAKE A
LOOK AT IT AND- LET STAFF KNOW
IF WE IDENTIFY ANY CONCERNS AT
THAT POINT. GREAT THANK YOU-
FINANCE ANY COMMENTS. LENITION
MATTER DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
NOTHING TO ADD AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU THANK YOU COLLEAGUES.
OKAY I DON'T HAVE ANY COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS EITHER SO YOU'RE
TO HOLD OPEN AND I MOVE ON.
FROM ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN SORRY I
SHOULD LOOK. SOMEBODY LOOKING
OUT FOR THE HANDS I FORGET TO
LOOK OUT FOR HER NEEDS OKAY.
HERE AGAIN. ISSUE SEVEN IS
ACTUALLY TWO ISSUES COMBINED-
BUT THEY'RE CONNECTED IN THAT
THEY'RE BOTH FOOD RELATED
REQUEST FOR INCARCERATED
POPULATION. THE FIRST IS
RELATED TO OUR INSTITUTION
CANTEENS WERE REQUESTING TWO
MILLION DOLLARS INMATE WELFARE
FUND AND SEVEN POSITIONS IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
TO MEET THE GROWING DEMAND FOR-
CANTEEN AND PROVIDING COULD BE
INCREASED ACCESS TO CANTEEN
LINES. THE SECOND INVOLVES AT
INCREASING THE STATEWIDE
FEEDING RATE BY TWENTY TWO
CENTS PER INMATE PER DAY FOR
FOOD AND SUPPLIES TO UPDATE THE
FOOD MENU FOR ALL OUR INMATES
TO PROVIDE HEALTHY FOOD OPTIONS
AT MEALS. THE COST OF THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD DEPEND ON THE
ESTIMATED POPULATION THE
INSTITUTIONS BUT WILL BE
APPROXIMATELY. SEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY WISPY
DAYS KEITH ROBINSON WHO'S THE
DEPARTMENT FOOD ADMINISTRATOR
IN ANY CA CST ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF THE ACCOUNTING
SERVICES BRANCH I THINK WE'LL
START WITH A EMAIL TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE NEED FOR
THE CANTEEN RESOURCES. THANK
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON. SO
CANTEEN TO GIVE YOU AN OVERVIEW
THE CANTEEN IS THE BASICALLY
THE STORES THAT THE IMAGE SHOPS
SHOP IN INSIDE THE INSTITUTION.
THEY ARE VERY IMPORTANT TO THE
PROGRAMMING FOR THE INMATES
THAT IMPORTANT BENEFIT TO THE
ENEMY AN INMATE WELFARE FUND
EXIST ONLY TO BENEFIT THE IN
MAY. SO THE MAJORITY OF THE
REVENUE INSIDE THE INMATE
WELFARE FUND IS BASED ON SALES-
FROM THOSE CAMPAIGN. OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS THE CAMPAIGN
HAS REALLY INCREASED THE VOLUME
NOT ONLY OF SALES OF GOODS. AND
THAT IS MOSTLY DUE TO THE
INCREASE AND PRIVILEGE LEVELS
FOR THE INMATES. SO THEY HAVE
MORE SHOPPING BUT ALSO THE
CANTEEN HAS BECOME- THE PLACE
WHERE THEY DISTRIBUTE BUT HE'S
THESE- OVER THE COUNTER.
MEDICATIONS THAT THE INMATES
USED TO HAVE TOGO TO MEDICAL
APPOINTMENTS FOR THEY CAN NOW
GET ATKINS TEAM. AS WELL AS WE
NOW DISTRIBUTE READERS- TO THE
CANTEEN POPULATION. SO THAT IS
ALSO BROUGHT A LOT OF INMATES
WHO NORMALLY DIDN'T SHOP- IF
THEY WERE INDIGENT IN THE
CANTEEN- FOR THOSE SERVICES- IN
ORDER. IS RICK- ADDITIONAL SO
POSITION. OF FIRST A COUPLE OF
THE INSTITUTIONS THAT HAVE VERY
SPECIFIC- DIFFICULTIES WITH
CANTEEN- THAT COULD BE BACK OUT
FACILITIES. WHICH TAKE
ADDITIONAL TIME- RATHER THAN
HAVING THE INMATES DOWN THE
LINE IT ALSO- HAS SOME
INSTITUTIONS THAT HAVE. VARIOUS
TRAINING- PROGRAMMING AND
VOCATIONAL TRAINING WHICH
REQUIRES THE CANTEENS TO BE
OPEN SIX OR SEVEN DAYS A WEEK I
LONGER HOURS TO ACCOMMODATE ALL
THE INMATES TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
GOING TO THEIR PROGRAMMING. FOR
THEIR CLASSES THANK INSTOCK
CANTEEN. I STATE POSITIONS FOR
THAT WORLD REQUESTING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE
ABILITY TO PURCHASE ITEMS FOR
SALE OUR PROPOSAL INCLUDES AN
INCREASE TO THE MAXIMUM LIMIT
FOR SPENDING OF A 10% INCREASE-%
IN FUTURE YEARS THE LAST TIME
THAT THAT HAS BEEN INCREASED
REMIXES TWO THOUSAND. OKAY AND
CAN YOU TELL US SOME MORE ABOUT
THE- HEALTHY MENU OPTIONS.
WORSE YES THE HEALTHY MENU
OPTIONS IN THE CANTEEN- WE'VE
WORKED WITH A MISTER ROBINSON
WHO HEARING ABOUT AND ALSO THE
CHIEF DIETICIAN AT C. C. H. C.
S. I'M CURRENTLY ABOUT 11% OF
OUR SALES AT CANTEEN ARE
CONSIDERED HEALTHY ITEMS- WE
HAVE THINGS LIKE STRING CHEESE-
HOUSE FISH. AND VEGETABLES- LOW
SALT ITEMS. SALSA YOGURT- WHERE
WE CAN. TALK ABOUT A HOME LAST
SO WE ARE REALLY WORKING ON
TRYING TO INCREASE THOSE
HEALTHY ITEMS THAT WE DO OFFER
AT THE CANTEEN FOR INMATES. AND
WE WORK WITH- THAT COULD
ADMINISTRATOR AND THE DIETICIAN
IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT THOSE
NUTRITION LABELS. AND IN THE
FUTURE WE WILL BE WORKING WITH-
I'M MORE CONTRACTED ITEMS. FOR
SALE IN THE CANTEENS OF THOSE
ITEMS. MAYBE NEXT WEEK COULD GO
IF WE COULD- BOTTOM SURE WE CAN
GO TO- KEITH ROBBINS WILL TALK
ABOUT THE EFFORT TO GET OUR
REGULAR MEALS- TO INCLUDE MORE
OF FRUITS AND VEGETABLES AND
FRESH ITEMS. WONDERFUL OKAY.
YES KEITH ROBINSON ON CDC ARE.
BACK IN. TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
MYSELF ALONG WITH. THE CHIEF A
DIETARY FROM HEALTH CARE
DECIDED TO DEVELOP OF. FOLLOW
THE GUIDELINES OF THE BOAT OF
THE DIETARY GUIDELINES FOR
AMERICANS TO TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
VERSION AND NOW THERE IS A. TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY FIVE WHERE. IT OF. WANTS
US TO CREATE A HEALTHIER EATING
PATTERNS FOR ADULTS. AND SO WE
REDESIGNED AND REDEVELOPED THE
MENU TO INCLUDE MORE FRESH
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES
THROUGHOUT THE DAY. WELL AND
WILK AND WE PARED BACK ALONG
WITH IDENTIFYING. ON OUR STATE
STATEWIDE STANDARDIZED MENU HOW
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY BE-
DIABETIC CAN IDENTIFY
CARBOHYDRATE EXCHANGES SO
THEY'RE ABLE TO FEED OFF OF
THAT HE SMARTLY OFFER THE STATE
WIDE MENU THAT IS DEVELOPED.
THAT'S GREAT. WELL WE SELL
REALLY WONDERFUL. THE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- DO WE HAVE- WITH
EARLIER- MARIO THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE ON THE FIRST
ISSUE REGARDING THAT CANTEEN
RESOURCES WE HAVE NOT
IDENTIFIED ISSUES ON THE
PROPOSAL OF THE HEALTHY MENU
OPTIONS BUT WE DO NOT HAVE
CONSERVATIVE PROVIDING A MAKE
IT HEALTHY MENUS WHAT CITIES
ARE HAS BEEN DOING SINCE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY. WE DO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS BY THE PROS
FROM INSTRUCTORS WHICH THE
PRIMARY FOCUS OF THIS PROPOSAL
GIVEN THAT THE HEALTH NEEDS OR.
ASPEN ADOPTED- BARBARA. IF
YOU'LL COSTS AND EXCEEDED FOR
MULTIPLE WORKS THE FUNDING
RATES COME AT THREE. A CENTS
PER DAY. THEN THERE DIGITAL
THAT THE STARTING IS COME
HIGHERHIGHER OF BUYING THAT
DEALS TO ELIMINATE. COME FROM
READER SAVINGS UNCLE PLANT
OPERATION POSITION SUCH AS
FARMERS A LOT. AND WHILE THESE
POSITIONS AREN'T TO MAKE. THE
MINISTRY HAVE BEEN TO FEDERAL
HISTORICALLY AS A RESULT CITIES
ARE COURTS TYPICALLY HAPPENED
ABOUT THIRTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY IN SAVINGS-
FROM THESE VACANT POSITIONS.
AND THESE ARE HAVE TO CONTINUE
USING THE SAVE TO PAY FOR
COURSES OF THE COST OF THE
EMAILS. BUT INDICATED IT IS NOT
LEAVE THE SAVINGS WILL BE
SUFFICIENT TO COME THAT ENTIRE
HA. OF THE MATERIALS BEYOND THE
EXISTING FUNDING. BECAUSE THEY
THINK THAT THEY WILL HAVE A
LOWER VACANCIES TO THE PRISON
CLOSURES ARE PLANNED. AS WELL
AS THE END OF THE PANDEMIC. IN
THE TEMPORARY PASSCODE TO
POLICY THAT WAS IMPLEMENTED. IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WE
THAT IT DID LABOR. IS ON A NON
THAT CAN BE SAVING. THE
DEPARTMENT TO HAPPEN IN THE
BUDGET YOUR HOWEVER I DID THAT
ESTIMATE. AND HOW THE TOTAL
ESTIMATED SAVINGS WOULD BE USED
TO THE EXTENT IT DOESN'T ALL GO
TOWARDS THE EMAIL COSTS. FOR
MORE DUE TO THE HISTORICALLY
HIGH VACANCY WE'VE BEEN BACK IN
THE SHORT TERM REDIRECTING.
SAVINGS TO SUPPORT ANY MEAL IS
A REASONABLE ON A TEMPORARY
BASIS. IT IS GIVEN THE
HISTORICAL DIFFICULTY OF
FILLING THE BALLOT RATIONS
POSITION SUGGESTING THAT THERE
SHOULD BE SOME FUNDING IN THIS
AREA. I HAD GIVEN THE CURRENT
STATE OF THE GENERAL FUND
CONDITION IT MAY BE APPROPRIATE
TO UTILIZE OUT FOR THIS
PURPOSE. WE DO NOT THINK IT
SHOULD BE A LONG TERM STRATEGY
IS BECAUSE USING THE FUNDS FOR
THIS PURPOSE IS INCONSISTENT
WITH THE LEGISLATURE IS
INTENDED FOR PROVIDING THE
FUNDING FOR. OPERATIONS WE
SHOULD BE GOING TOWARDS.
REPAIRING THAT RETAINING CDCR
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH IS COMMON
IN. EXECUTIVE PRODUCER PARA.
FOR EXAMPLE THE REASON STUDY I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT. BILL DOLLAR
IN. NEED A NETWORK OLDEST
PERSON. THANK YOU FOR ARE
ACTUALLY NEEDED TO THE AYE
OPERATIONS VACANCY AND ADDRESS
THE OPERATION ORACLE AT SCHOOL
I MAD. THE KNOWLEDGE SEATS ARE
HOSTAGE A STEP. JUNE TWENTY
EIGHTY EIGHT RECRUIT EFFORTS
FOR THESE. I DON'T THINK
ADDITIONAL. COULD BE. FOR EXAM
KIDS. ARE CONSIDERED. OTHER
OPTIONS SUCH AS INCREASE PAY
RATE INSTITUTIONAL. HIGH BUT
RATES THE TRACK OR CANDIDATES-
POTENTIALLY HIRING CONTRACTORS
ON. BASIS USING THE EXISTING
VACANCY SAVINGS TELEVISION CAN
BE FILLED WITH SEVERAL SERVICE.
EMPLOYEES AND CONSIDERING
MAKING GREAT USE OF INMATES
FROM. FUNDS X. TRAINING THEM ON
THE NAY SKILLS. GIVEN THESE
FINDINGS WE ARE HERE IN THE FOR
US WE- REQUIREMENTS TO RECALL
ON NUMBER SAVINGS THE BUDGET
ARE OUT OF AT THE S. HOW PLANTS
USE A TOTAL ESTIMATE SAVINGS
INTO ONE POINT TWO. AND INTEL
THAT INFORMATION COMES OUT.
RECOMMEND US ARE SOME DACIAN
WITHHOLD OPTIONAL THE GOVERNOR
TO PUT OLD UNTIL THAT. WE HAD A-
BECAUSE IT COULD. BE BIG THAT
ADDITION TELEPHONE IT'S NOT ACT
NECESSARY AND BAY CITY HE SAID
FROM BECAUSE- WERE BE SELF TO
COVER THE FULL OF IN MIDDLE.
AND THEN A LOT OF EVERY DAY
MISTER CLASS ARE COMBINED
DETAIL PLANS ADDRESS THE PANEL.
WORK AND INTO IN THE BUILDING
PLAN IT IS SHOULD THE MANAGER
IT IS A- OF OUR- TO GO MORE.
BEYONDADDITIONAL EFFORTS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR A
ANOTHER ISSUE THAT WAS ON OUR
LOW. BUT IT WAS A VERY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I ANY LET'S SEE
WE'VE GOT FINANCE. COMMENT I
LET ME SEE DEPARTMENT ASIDE- I
WE ARE CONVINCED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE IS NECESSARY AS WE
ANTICIPATE THAT THE SALARY
SAVINGS ARE TEMPORARY AND THEY
WON'T BE AVAILABLE ON GOING DCR
IS INCREASING THEIR HIRING
EFFORTS AND ALSO BE REDUCED-
DUE TO THE TWO PERSON CLOSURES
THAT ARE THAT ARE FORTHCOMING.
AS THESE CHANGES TAKE PLACE IT
REDUCES THE AMOUNT OF THE
SALEABLE POSITION- I FEEL
SALARY SAVINGS EXCUSE ME TO RE
DIRECT TOWARDS THE FOOD BUDGET-
SO AND PROPOSAL DESIGNATES.
THAT SOME OF SAVINGS AS THE
ALLEY ON MY WHICH IS WHY THE
REQUEST IS ONLY THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN. THE FEEDING SPENDING
PRIOR TO THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE HEALTHY MEN YOU KNOW-
COMPARED TO THE NEW HEALTHY
MENU COSTS. I ALSO I THINK
THERE ARE SOME DIFFICULTIES AB.
CURRENTLY JUST FILLING
POSITIONS DUE TO COVER IT SO
AGAIN WE ANTICIPATE THAT THE
SALARY SAVINGS WON'T BE
AVAILABLE ON GOING. OKAY OKAY
THANK YOU I JUST HAVE A QUICK
QUESTION ON THE A GOING BACK TO
THE CANTEEN RESOURCES ASKING
FOR- SEVEN MORE POSITIONS OF
HOW HOW WOULD YOU HOW DOES THAT
WORK. HOW DO YOU DECIDE WHERE
IN TERMS OF WORK WHICH
INSTITUTIONS THOSE SEVEN
POSITIONS WILL WILL GO TO. HI
THIS IS ABCS- WE DIDN'T TAKE A
CLOSE LOOK AT THE OPERATIONS OF
OUR INSTITUTIONS AND WE HAVE
DETERMINED WHICH SEVEN THOSE
WILL BE- AND THE REASONS THEY
WERE CHOSEN WAS BECAUSE ONE OF
THE BAG OUT FACILITY THERE'S
ONE THAT'S A COMPLETE BACKUP
FACILITY AND THERE'S SEVERAL
THAT HAVE BACKED OUT YARDS. AND
WHEN YOU DO BAG OUT THERE'S A
LOT OF WORK THAT GOES ALONG
WITH THAT YOU HAVE TO SEND OUT
SHOPPING LIST OF THE HOUSING
UNITS GIVEN BACK BAG UP THE
ITEMS AND THEN DISTRIBUTE THEM
AND THAT REQUIRES LOADING
TRUCKS MOVING THEM TO SALLY
PORTS AND THEN DISTRIBUTING
THOSE ORDERS. BUT I HOPE
PROCESS TAKES A LONG TIME SO
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE CONSIDERED THE OTHER THING
WE CONSIDERED WISE WHAT KIND OF
PROGRAMMING IS GOING ON IN
THOSE INSTITUTIONS OR
VOCATIONAL TRAINING WHICH TAKE
THE INCARCERATED PEOPLE OUT
INTO PROGRAMMING A MAJORITY OF
THE TIME AND SO WE WANT TO WE
HAVE TO KEEP THE CANTONS OPEN
LONGER AT THOSE FACILITIES. THE
ONE THAT CASE WE ALSO NEED MORE
STAFF TO RUN THE CANTEENS
LONGER FOR THOSE WERE A COUPLE
OF THE OTHER AND CONSIDERATION
WAS THE TYPE OF INMATE
POPULATION AT THE INSTITUTIONS
AND IN SOME CASES WE HAVE HERE
CAN YOU THIS HENCE OUR PATIENTS.
ARE PEOPLE THAT NEED. AND
BECAUSE OF THEIR DAY. MENTAL
CAME. THAT SHOPPING TAKES A LOT
ONE. THEY WERE A LOT MORE
ASSISTANCE IN HELPING WITH
THEIR ORDERS AT THE WINDOWS. SO
WHAT DOES IT MEAN ITEMS THAT
LOOKED AT TO DETERMINE WHAT.
AND INSTITUTIONS WE WOULD BE
GIVING US. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH COLLEAGUES. CENTER NEWMAN
I HAVE A WHAT IS PROBABLY
REALLY MONDAY CRISIS I I'VE
ACTUALLY NEVER HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHOP IN A- IN A
CANTEEN AND IT IS. AN
INSTITUTION SO BACK TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE- MARGINS ON
SALES SUPPORT THE INMATE
WELFARE FUND. HOW DO SHARE
PRICES COMPARED TO CANTEEN
AGAINST WHAT YOU MIGHT FIND IN
THE- OUTSIDE WORLD AND HOW ARE
THOSE PRICES SET. IN SO HOW
THEIR SETS I HAVE TO I CAN PUT
SOME THINGS TOGETHER AND GIVE
THOSE TO YOU SPECIFICALLY FOR
CERTAIN ITEMS THANK OUT OF
POCKET BETTER THAN THE CATHOLIC
CASTING- AND AS FAR AS THEIR
SET WE HAVE A MARKET GOAL THAT
WE CHARGE SO FIRST WE GO OUT TO
BID ON ON THE FOOD ITEMS THAT
WE PURCHASED AND WE HAVE THE
STOCK MARKET THAT GOES ON THOSE
ITEMS- AND THAT. THE MARKET IS
OUR PROFIT. AND THAT IS WHAT
YOU TO. NOT ONLY WHAT WE NEED
FOR THE COST OF GOODS SOLD-
MOSTLY OUR CABLE BUT IT ALSO
PROVIDES BENEFITS TO AND MAKES.
ANY MONEY THAT WE MAKE. THOSE
CURRENTLY- ARE ITEMS SUCH AS WE
SUPPORT VISITING I WHEN THEY
HAVE A GOOD DAY. WE PROVIDE
CABLE- WE PROVIDE MOVIE
RENTALS. I WOULD PROVIDE AND
LOOK AT LATICS SUPPLIES- AND WE
ALSO SUPPORT A LOT OF GRANTS-
ARE YOU CAN GET. REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMMING- AND GET THEM
IMPACT SERVICES. IT'S ARE YOU
JUST AGAIN MY OWN SORT OF THE
BACK. CITY DID SO THERE'S- SAID
ON A ON AND IT IS A RISK FOR
THE WITH THE SETTING PRICES OR
IS IT. KIND OF MORE OF AND TO
MAKE THAT HAVE IS WE HAVE A
MARK. THAT I REVIEW EVERY YEAR
TO IF THE STILL REASONABLE
MARKET RATE AND WE TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT ANY EXPENDITURES THAT
WERE HAPPENING AND WHAT OUR
SALES ARE- AND ALSO TRYING TO
KEEP AND MAINTAIN THE
APPROPRIATE FUND BALANCE IN THE
IN A LAW FIRM. SINCE WE DO HOLD
THAT AS A TRUST WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE RESOURCES. IT IS
REVIEWED ON A FEDERAL BASIS-
BASED ON OUR PERFORMANCE FROM
THE PREVIOUS YEAR. INDIVIDUALLY
AT CANTEENS AS AS THEIR OWN A
STORE AND WE MAKE SURE THAT
THEY ARE PROFITABLE AND NOT
LOSING MONEY FOR THE- PROJECT
SO I GOT A DEGREE WORK FOR ME
BUT I DO I DO I THINK. IT WOULD
BE HELPFUL TO SEE HOW THOSE
PRICES TO COMPARE SO THEY WILL
DEFINITELY PROVIDE A LIST OF
SOME OF OUR ITEMS ALONG WITH
WHAT THE CURRENT SALE PRICE
WOULD BE AT. LEAST ONE. THANK
YOU MUCH. OKAY THANKS IN CENTER.
PRETENDING THANK YOU. THIRTY
MINUTES- I. GUESS I'D HAVE TO
SAY AT THIS POINT- AND
CERTAINLY THERE'S TIME FOR
FURTHER STUDY- I DON'T. REALLY
UNDERSTAND THE FULL EQUATION
BETWEEN- YOU KNOW UNFILLED
POSITIONS POSITIONS NEEDED
DECLINING OVERALL DECLINING.
CENSUS OF POPULATION- IN
INCREASING DEMAND BY THE
INMATES- ALL LEADING TO THIS.
SORT OF NET. POSITION OF- SEVEN
POSITIONS I GUESS AND THEN
THERE ARE APPROXIMATELY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS- ANY IT ANY
FURTHER. SORT OF BREAKDOWN OF
THAT MATH WOULD BE HELPFUL TO
ME JUST UNDERSTAND IT'S NOT THE
LARGEST IN THE WORLD RELATIVE
TO THE STATE BUDGET OR- OR EVEN
EVEN THIS SUB BUDGET BUT-
SOMEBODY MUST'VE DONE THAT
ENOUGH ALREADY I'M ASSUMING.
YOU KNOW IN THE SPIRIT OF NOT
CREATING MOE WORK I JUST LIKE
TO SEE- HALL THAT ADDITION AND
SUBTRACTION ENDED UP AT THIS
AMOUNT. MAY BE A ONE PAGE- GIVE
ME US A QUESTION ABOUT- B. WHO
JUMP AROUND HERE A LITTLE BIT
ON THE INCREASE HEALTHY MENU
OPTIONS AWAY I'M UNDERSTANDING
THIS IS. THAT THIS. THESE
AVERAGES IN TERMS OF HEIGHT
WEIGHT AND SO FORTH THAT ARE
LAID OUT- I'M PAGES PAGE
THIRTEEN OF MY GENDER COULD.
THAT THOSE ARE NOT WHAT WE-
THOSE ARE NOT THE OUTCOMES WE
WANT THOSE OR THE CALORIC LEVEL
SO WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE IN
ORDER TO. ACCOMPLISH REDUCED
OBESITY AND BETTER HEALTH IS
THAT THE IDEA THAT SOMEBODY
WOULD COME BACK HERE AND SAY
THAT THESE ARE BRIDGES ARE. YOU
KNOW OUR OUR BETTER BODY WEIGHT
INDEX AND WHAT WERE SEEN ON
THIS PAGE. YES SIR KEITH
ROBINSON CENTER- WHEN WE
DETERMINED WHAT THE CATTLE
CALORIE LEVEL WOULD BE WE
ACTUALLY HAD REACHED OUT TO.
CHIEF OF DIETARY REACHED OUT TO
SEE WHAT THE AVERAGE WEIGHT.
REQUIREMENTS YOU KNOW. OF OUR
INMATE POPULATION BOTH MALE AND
FEMALE AND WE ONCE WE DETERMINE
WHAT THAT WAS. WE FOLLOW THE
DIETARY GUIDELINES FOR
AMERICANS PATTERNS IT'S THE WE
MODEL BACK. GOOD MEANING YOU
MODELED IT WHAT I'M GETTING AT
IS YOUR I WAS SITTING HERE
HOPING THAT TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED
CALORIES A DAY. IF I'M READING
THIS RIGHT HERE YOU'RE SAYING
THE CORK INTAKE RECOMMENDED A
COURT CLERK INTAKE IS BASED ON
THESE FACTORS YES BUT YOU
WOULDN'T WANT. EARLIER IN THIS
REPORT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
WANTING TO REDUCE THE INCIDENCE
OF OBESITY. I'M JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND I DON'T THINK TWENTY
FOUR HUNDRED CALORIES A DAY FOR
EXAMPLE ON A FIVE FOOT NINE. A
MALE WOULD. TYPICALLY SUPPORT.
WERE SUSTAIN A HUNDRED NINETY
SEVEN POUNDS OVER TIME. I'M
BEING FIVE FOOT NINE MYSELF
ALONE I HAVE SOME LIVED
EXPERIENCE WITH THAT BUT- BUT
I'M I'M ASSUMING THAT THE
TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED CALORIES IS
INTENDED TO- WITH THIS KIT WITH
THESE CHANGES IN THE CNTEEN IN
WITH THE SHIP MENU CHANGES IS
INTENDED TO- THESE MANAGERS ARE
INTENDED TO HIT. A COURT. LEVEL
PER DAY THAT THEY BRINGS OF
THESE EIGHTS DOWN WHETHER IT'S
MALE OR FEMALE THAT'S ALL I'M
REALLY ASKING I DON'T I DO
TRUST YOU RESEARCH AND I'M NOT
QUESTIONING THAT WHATSOEVER GEN
UNDERSTAND. IF THAT'S THE GOAL
YES SIR. OKAY GREAT THAT'S
HELPFUL THANK YOU FOR
CONFIRMING THAT IN AND OF. FOR
THE ONLY- WE TALKED ABOUT HIM
HE WAS GONNA COOPER LEADERS
SOMETIME WE HAVE TO VOTE- NOT
TODAY BUT- THIS IDEA THAT THESE
FUNDS. AN OLD LEGISLATIVE
INTENT WAS NOT TO USE THE FUNDS
I'M GOING BACK TO THE- THE
POSITIONS THE MEANWHILE FOR
FRONT. POSITIONS BLOOD BUT
RATHER DEFERRED MAINTENANCE OF
I'M UNDERSTANDING. RACKLEY IN
IN I HEARD IT ON AN INFOPRINT
LEAVE- FIRMLY THAT THERE'S A
BACKLOG OF DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
THAT'S PROBABLY PRETTY BIG-
WOULD IT BE WOULD IT BE. AN
ALTERNATIVE RECOMMENDATION TO
SAY THAT THAT BACKLOG NEEDS TO
BE TAKEN CARE OF WITH WITH
CAPITAL FUNDS ARE TYPICAL ONE
TIME FUNDS TO GET CAUGHT UP-
ISN'T IT PERHAPS IS THE
MEANWHILE FOR FUN. IT HAS
PROVEN TO HAVE A FAILED TO BE
INSUFFICIENT. OVER TIME TO TAKE
CARE OF DEFERRED MAINTENANCE I
JUST WONDERED IF YOU'VE LOOKED
AT THAT. ANALYSIS ARE TAKEN UP
THAT ANALYSIS OR WHETHER OR NOT
THAT'S THAT'S WORTH TAKING UP
AS YOU KNOW MAYBE MAYBE WHAT
WE'RE SEEING HERE IS THE IN THE
MEANWHILE FOR PHONE MAY HAVE.
CERTAINLY BEEN INTENDED TO DO
THAT- AND HAVE FAILED- NOT BEEN
ABLE TO CATCH UP OR KEEP UP.
WITH HIM AGAIN- SO I WILL. I
WANT TO BE REDUNDANT BUT YOU
HEARD MY SORT OF- SUPPOSE ALL
SUPPOSE WE HAD A- YOU KNOW
CAPITAL CONTRIBUTIONS ON A ONE
TIME BASIS SEPARATE IN TE FOR
A PARTY KEPT CATCH OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE RATHER THAN TRYING
TO DEPEND ON THIS FRONT.
MOREOVER THE L. A. M. I
WOULDN'T YOU KNOW THERE'S A FEW
DIFFERENT THINGS GOING ON HERE
SAID THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
FUNDING IS ACCESS SEPARATE
ISSUE AS WELL AS A MAJOR
WELFARE FUND- THAT MONEY WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT IS FOR PAN
OPERATIONS POSITIONS WHICH ARE
INTENDED FOR MAINTAINING DONTE
STARKS EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE
ARE SEPARATE FROM THE- DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE. FOR THE IS NOW
WHAT THE- MEETINGS. AND
COMMISSIONER EARLY TO SEE THE
STARS IN. TURN OVER TO MICHAEL
KAYLA. THANKS I AM KIND AND
LOOSE AND ERRORS A POSITION
THAT SEEKS ARE BASED AT THE
PRESENT THE PLAN OPERATIONS
STAFF THAT ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
MAINTAINING. THE ONGOING
MAINTENANCE PREVENTATIVE- TYPE
MAINTENANCE OF THE FACILITY-
AND THEN CDCR HAS THAT SEPARATE
BUDGET FOR SPECIAL REPAIRING
FOR MAINTENANCE WHICH TENDS TO
BE IT'S HARD TO UNDERSTAND
SOMETIMES LARGER PROJECTS. THAN
A TYPICAL YOU KNOW FIXING A
TOILET BUT MORE LIKE REPAIRING
A ROOF- IN SO. YOU ARE CORRECT
THERE IS A VERY SIGNIFICANT
BACKLOG OF DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
AT CDCR INSTITUTIONS THE
DEPARTMENT ESTIMATES IT TO BE
AROUND A BILLION DOLLARS- AT
LEAST A BILLION DOLLARS OF
KNOWN PROJECTS BUT- THERE'S
REASON TO THINK THAT IT'S
ACTUALLY IN. SUMMER IN THE
SEVERAL BILLION VERY
POTENTIALLY HIGHER- SO. AND
THERE IS A I BELIEVE THAT IF
OUR NEXT HEARING WILL BE
DISCUSSING IT MORE ON DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND A PROPOSAL ONE
TIME ALLOCATION FOR- AUGMENTING
THE DEPARTMENTS DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BUDGET- WE DID DO A
REPORT LAST YEAR. ON MANAGING
BETTER MANAGING PRISON
INFRASTRUCTURE IN WHICH WE HAVE
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS FOR HOW
THE LEGISLATURE CAN- HELP. AS
THE STATE DEVELOP A PLAN TO-
BETTER MANAGE PRISON
INFRASTRUCTURE AND I AM HAPPY
TO FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR STAFF
WITH MORE INFORMATION ON THAT I
THOUGHT WOULD BE HELPFUL. YEAH
THAT WOULD ASK A QUESTION- YES
FOR NOW THAT'S A GREAT ANSWER
FOR NOW I THINK IF YOU COULD
JUST DISTRIBUTE I WOULD S.
THROUGH THE CHAIR JUST
DISTRIBUTE TO THE COMMITTEE-
IT'LL LAST YEAR'S- REPORT
ANALYSIS IS SOUNDS LIKE BE VERY
HELPFUL AND GOOD. FOR US THIS
WEEK- APPROACH. A FURTHER
HEARINGS ON THE TOPIC IN- IN
AGAIN I WOULD JUST LEAVE OUT
THERE ANY ANY. UPDATED
SUGGESTIONS YOU HAVE FOR-
CREATING- A MORE SUSTAINABLE
PLAN FOR BOTH. ONGOING DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE- A BY STAFF AND
ALSO THE LARGER CAPITAL FUND
CERTAINLY WOULD BE APPRECIATED
SO THANK YOU AND LOOK FORWARD
TO RECEIVING THE MATERIAL.
GREAT THANK YOU SENATOR- WE GET
EVERYBODY FINANCED LMAO. NO
MORE COMMENTS. THE MORE HANDS
UP OKAY LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE.
EIGHT MADAM CHAIRMAN NAMES
DOING READER AND I'M WITH CCHS
FISCAL SERVICES ARE YOU ABLE TO
HEAR ME. YES GO AHEAD. GREAT WE
HAVE A REQUEST FOR OUR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT SECTION- OF THE FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS AND- TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND TWENTY THREE
POSITIONS GROWING TO. ELEVEN
POINT SEVEN MILLION AND SEVENTY
FIVE POSITIONS IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE- THESE POSITIONS
ARE TO ADDRESS SOME- PATIENT
SAFETY CONCERNS- WE HAD AN
INDEPENDENT ASSESSMENT OF OUR
PATIENT SAFETY PROGRAM DONE BY
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SAN FRANCISCO- THE DEFINITION
FROM ACCIDENTAL OR PREVENTABLE
INJURIES PRODUCED BY MEDICAL
CARE- SO. WE HAVE SOME
DEFICIENCIES IDENTIFIED I HAVE
A NET LAMBERT- THE DIRECTOR
WORKING ON PROGRAMMING DR JOHN
DUNLAP FROM WORKING ON PROGRAM
HERE TO HELP ANSWER QUESTIONS
BUT- THESE POSITIONS ARE TO- AT
SOME POSITIONS TO OUR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT SECTION UNITS IN THE
INSTITUTIONS TO ADDRESS PATIENT.
SAFETY CONCERNS IDENTIFIED IN
THE REPORT. OKAY- THE FINANCE.
THIS IS MICHAEL PLACEMENT FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE STUFF
AND AT THIS TIME OKAY AND THE
ALEJO. R. O. L. L. WE DON'T
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THAT
PROPOSAL OVER ALL HOWEVER WE
KNOW THAT- THAT NUMBER POSITION
YOURS DO YOU NEED TO BE
ADJUSTED THE SOMETHING WE HAE
DISCUSSED WITH ADMINISTRATION
THEY HAVE ACKNOWLEDGED. SO I
DON'T HAVE NOTE FROM THE
RECEIVERS OFFICER NOTED THAT-
THAT NUMBER POSITIONS WOULD
GROW OVER TIME AND THE WAY THIS
IS BEING IMPLEMENTED AS EACH
PERSON WOULD GET TO POSITION
ALLOCATED. AND THE STYLO THREE
ARMS IN TERMS OF WHICH PERSONS
GOT THOSE POSITIONS. ANKARA
THIS WILL BE TAKEN ALTHOUGH
FIVE PRESIDENTS HARM THAT
MINISTRATION HAS. PLANS TO
CLOSE TO PRISONS INCLUDING THE
DUAL EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTION IN
TWENTY ONE POINT TUNE. BUT
THESE POSITIONS DO NOT ACCOUNT
FOR THOSE CLOSURES AND SO THAT
THOSE CLOSE PRISON FACILITY
ALLOCATED POSITIONS. THE
PROPOSAL SHOULD BE REDUCED
FIGHT FOR POSITIONS AND ABOUT
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
ANNUALLY ALPHEUS. OKAY. ANNETTE
MISS LAMBERT LEFT. THE COMPANY
AND I AM NOT LAMBERT DEPUTY
DIRECTOR QUALITY MANAGEMENT AND
PATIENT SAFETY CAN YOU HEAR ME
OK YES GO AHEAD OKAY- AS AS
DEPUTY DIRECTOR READER
EXPLAINED AS THE RECEIVER HAD
COMMISSION OVER THE COURSE OF
SEVERAL YEARS SOME INDEPENDENT
EVALUATIONS OF DIFFERENT AREAS
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES IN THE
PRISON SYSTEM. TO RESOLVE THE
ISSUES THAT WERE STILL
OUTSTANDING FOR THE
RECEIVERSHIP SO THESE ARE
ISSUES THAT- STILL NEED TO BE
TACKLED FOR US TO BE RELEASED
FROM FEDERAL RECEIVERSHIP AND
FOR OUR SYSTEM TO BE DELEGATED
BACK TO YOU AS STATE CONTROL.
ONE OF THOSE AREAS IS PATIENT
SAFETY AND SO M. AS A DEPUTY
DIRECTOR READER EXPLAINED THE
UC SAN FRANCISCO AND WAS. ASKED
TO COMPLETE AN ASSESSMENT OVER
PATIENT SAFETY AS SYSTEM AT OUR
THIRTY FIVE INSTITUTIONS ARE
YOU SOUNDS GOOD COMPLETED THAT
REVIEW AND FOUND THAT WE HAD-
SOME SIGNIFICANT GAPS IN OUR
PATIENTS SAFETY. SYSTEM AND
THEY ALSO FOUND THAT WE WERE
UNDERSTAFFED BOTH TO SUPPORT
OUR CURRENT LEVEL OF SERVICES
AS WELL AS ADDRESSING THE GAPS
IDENTIFIED. AS SO THIS REQUEST
IS TO ALLOW US TO PUT INTO
PLACE SOME OF THOSE SYSTEMS AT
CRITICAL SYSTEMS THAT UCSF. I'M
IDENTIFIED AS MISSING AND ARE
AM SYSTEM. AND WHAT WE ALSO DID
IS WE TRIED TO LEVERAGE OUR
EXISTING STAFFING MODELS SO YOU
CASF HAD RECOMMENDED A MUCH
RICHER AND PROPOSAL. FOR
STASHING AND WE BELIEVE THAT WE
CAN LEVERAGE SOME OF OUR
EXISTING CLINICAL STAFF IT
REDUCES THE BURDEN ON AT. ON
THE GENERAL FUND AND TAXPAYERS
SO WE'VE WE'VE TRIED TO REALLY
AND- MAKE THAT AS STREAMLINED
AS POSSIBLE AS EFFICIENT AS
POSSIBLE USING OUR EXISTING.
RESOURCES WITHIN THE DIVISION.
AND BEYOND THIS EVALUATION BY
UC SAN FRANCISCO WE HAD ALREADY
SEEN AS SOME ISSUES WITH OUR
STAFFING MODEL AND THIS IS A
MODEL THAT WE HAD PUT TOGETHER
IN JULY OF TWENTY FOURTEEN IT
ESTABLISHES EIGHT A UNIT OF
STAFF WHO ARE DEDICATED TO
QUALITY MANAGEMENT PATIENT
SAFETY WITHIN EACH PRESENT. AND
WE USED EXISTING RESOURCES TO
PUT THIS UNIT TOGETHER AND WHAT
WE FOUND IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE
DID OUR OWN INTERNAL
ASSESSMENTS IS THAT WE HAD SOME
SOME PROBLEMS WITH THE LEVEL OF
RESOURCING OF FOR OUR STAFFING
SOME SOME STAFF THAT WE-
BELIEVE COULD BE FULLY
DEDICATED TO YOU QUALITY
MANAGEMENT WE ACTUALLY WERE
UNABLE TO FULLY. RE DIRECT THEM
TO Q. M. AND THEY WERE AND
THESE ARE STAFF PARTICULAR THEY
WERE PULLED FOR DENTAL
FUNCTIONS. SO THIS PROPOSAL
MAKES THOSE POSITIONS HOLE AND
IT ALLOWS FOR A SOLID STAFFING
STRUCTURE FOR OUR THIRTY FIVE
INSTITUTIONS ARE M. AS LA POINT
ELLIE- POINTED OUT THE- WITH
THE CLOSURE OF SOME PRISONS AS-
ULTIMATELY THIRTY THREE
PRESENTS. I GUESS I'M A SOLID
THE STAFFING STRUCTURE FOR
THEIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT AND
PATIENT SAFETY AT PROGRAMS IN
ADDITION THIS AT THIS REQUEST
SETS UP A SMALL UNIT OF ROOT
CAUSE ANALYSIS EXPERTS. WHICH
WE WERE DEPLOYED FROM
HEADQUARTERS TO ASSIST
INSTITUTIONS AND AS IN
PERFORMING THOROUGH INCREDIBLE-
CAUSING GALAXIES WHICH IS AN
ESSENTIAL PART OF OUR PATIENTS
SAFETY AT PROGRAM. THE QUALITY
MANAGEMENT AND PATIENT SAFETY A
PROGRAM WITHIN OUR SYSTEM. THIS
IS THE SYSTEM WE USE FOR
ROUTINE MONITORING OF OUR ALL
OF OUR MAJOR HEALTH CARE AT
PROCESSES SO ALL OF OUR
CRITICAL HEALTHCARE PROCESSES
ALL OVER CRITICAL PATIENT
OUTCOMES. THIS IS THE SYSTEM
FOR ROUTINE MONITORING OF OUR
SYSTEM AS WELL AS I. YOUR
TIGHTENING THAT THOSE QUALITY
PROBLEMS THAT ARE IDENTIFYING
AT THAT ARE IDENTIFIED
ADDRESSING THEM THROUGH
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
IMPROVEMENT TECHNIQUES SUCH AS
LEAN SIX SIGMA SUCH AS ROOT
CAUSE ANALYSIS. AND ADDRESSING
THOSE ISSUES TO PROTECT OUR
PATIENTS. THIS IS CONSIDERED AN
ESSENTIAL PART OF ANY
HEALTHCARE ORGANIZATION AND WE
REALLY NEED FOR THIS TO BE AS
STRONG FULLY FUNCTIONAL AT
PROGRAM IN ORDER TO PROTECT OUR
PATIENTS AND TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE AN EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- ANY OTHER-
COMMENTS WE DON'T HAVE.
COLLEAGUES NOTHING OKAY I'M NOT
MISSING ALL RIGHT OF WELL WE'RE
GONNA HOLD OPEN APPRECIATE ALL
OF YOUR WORK- ON THIS AND- WE'D
LIKE TO MOVE ON TO ISSUE NINE.
THAT'S THE LAST ONE OKAY. OKAY
ISSUE NINE ALMOST DONE. THIS IS
OUR FINAL ISSUE ON THE AGENDA
ITS REQUEST FOR RESOURCES TO
IMPLEMENT ANOTHER BILL PASSED
LAST YEAR WHICH WAS SB ONE
THIRTY TWO HAD TO DO WAS
TRANSGENDER NINE NON BINARY AND
INTERSEX INMATE HOUSING AND
SEARCH PREFERENCES OR QUESTIONS
FOR TWO POINT EIGHT MILLION
GENERAL FUND AND FIVE POINT
FIVE POSITIONS IN TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. TO
DEVELOP POLICIES AND PRACTICES
THAT FACILITATE SAFE HOUSING
FOR THE TRANSGENDER POPULATION
AND HOUSE TRANSGENDER INMATES
BASED ON THEIR GENDER IDENTITY-
WITH ME TODAY AS SHE CAPTAIN
SHANNON STARK CORRECTIONAL
ADMINISTRATOR DAN ROSS AND BEEN
BLIND AND WHOSE ARE INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY MANNER MANAGER I'D
LIKE TO TURN TO- CAPTAIN STARK
FIRST WE COULD TO TALK ABOUT-
THE REASON BEHIND. THIS
PROPOSAL. GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATORS- I'M CAPTAIN SHANNON
STARK AND- SO EVEN PRIOR TO S.
B. ONE THIRTY TO BE AND SIGNED
BY THE GOVERNOR- THE
DEPARTMENT- ESTABLISH A WORK
GROUP TO LOOK AT POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES RELATED TO THIS
POPULATION. I'M RECOGNIZING
THAT- THAT THEY ARE AT HIGHER
RISK FOR VICTIMIZATION THAT WE
NEED TO PUT IN PLACE ADDITIONAL
SAFETY PRECAUTIONS. IN HOUSING
ALAN'S AND PROGRAMMING- SO IT
WOULDN'T SB ONE THIRTY TWO WAS
WAS SIGNED- IT ACTUALLY
EXPANDED UPON SOME OF OUR
EXISTING POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES AND THEN REQUIRED-
ADDITIONAL- US TO DROP THE
DIGITAL POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
REGULATIONS- TO WORK TOWARDS
COMPLIANCE FROM NESTING ONE
THIRTY TWO. SB ONE THIRTY TWO
AND THE PRISON RAPE ELIMINATION
ACT OVERLAP IN MANY AREAS- ONE
SIGNIFICANT AREA IS IN THE
HOUSING PLACEMENT FOR TRANS
GENDER NON BINARY AND INTERSEX
INMATE POPULATION. SO WHERE
PRIA REQUIRES THAT WE DO A CASE
BY CASE REVIEW SB ONE THIRTY
TWO EXPANDS ON THIS AND
REQUIRES THAT NOT ONLY DO WE DO
A CASE BY CASE REVIEW. THAT WE
ASK EVERY INMATE WHO COMES OUR
CURRENT POPULATION AND
EVERYBODY WHO COMES INTO YOUR-
CDCR ABOUT THEIR GENDER
IDENTITY AND THEN IF THEY DO
IDENTIFY AS TRANS GENDER NON
BINARY OR INTERSEX. BUT WE ALSO
ASK THEM IF THEY'D LIKE TO
DESIGNATE TOWARDS SELECT A
SEARCH PREFERENCE REQUEST NOT
BEING- THE GENDER OF THE STAFF
MEMBER THEY'LL BE SEARCHING
THEM. AND THEN ALSO THEY WOULD
LIKE TO CHOOSE TO BE- HOUSE OF
A MALE OR FEMALE FACILITY SO IN
ORDER TO DO THAT WE WORKED WITH
OUR COUNTERPARTS OVER AT THE
ENTERPRISE INFORMATION
SERVICES- TO DEVELOP AN
ELECTRONIC FORM WHERE WE CAN-
THAT GUIDES OUR STAFF. TO ASK
INMATES ABOUT THEIR GENDER
IDENTITY AND THEN ALSO TO
CAPTURE INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR
SEARCH PREFERENCE REQUEST AND.
THEN ALSO ABOUT THEIR HOUSING
REQUEST. I THE SEARCH
PREFERENCE FOR. PIECES OF NEW-
A WHOLE NEW. PROCESS FOR. ARE
ALLOWING ENEMY SEARCH SELECT
THE GENDER OF THE STAFF MEMBER
THAT WILL BE SEARCHING THEM IS
NOW- AND REQUIRED A LOT OF WORK
AND- ALSO THE DEVELOPMENT. OF
TRAINING FOR OUR STAFF-
ADDITIONALLY- WE HAVE RIGHT
WHEN SB ONE THIRD SHE WAS FINE
BUT PRIOR TO IMPLEMENTATION WE
DID DEVELOP STOP ARE DEVELOPED.
I'M TRAINING WITH- STAFF
OVERSEE POST TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE WERE ABLE TO- TRAIN ALL
KINDS TO DO STUFF ON THE
REQUIREMENTS OF SB ONE THIRTY
TWO SO THAT WAS COMPLETED AND
WE REALLY HIT THE GROUND
RUNNING WITH IMPLEMENTATION. OF
THE REQUIREMENTS OF SB ONE
THIRTY TWO. SO I THINK THAT THE
OUTSIDE OVERVIEW OF KIND OF
WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW IF
THERE'S ANY- ANY QUESTIONS.
WELL I APPRECIATE ALL OF THAT-
HARD WORK IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE
VERY COMPREHENSIVE AND-
THOROUGH AND ANTICIPATING. YOU
KNOW THAT THIS OVERLAP THAT YOU
THAT YOU JUST EXPLAINED AND PUT
OUT THERE SO- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR A FOR THAT WORK- LOL.
WE DIDN'T RAISE CONCERNS ON
THIS PROPOSAL OKAY. OKAY NUMBER
COMMENTS FROM FINANCE
COLLEAGUES YES SENATOR NEWMAN.
QUESTION ON THE AMOUNT- SO- ONE
SP ONE THIRTY TWO WENT THROUGH-
THE ANALYSIS ASSUMED IT ONE
TIME COST BETWEEN A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS. FOR AN
UPDATE- OF THE SOUND SYSTEM AND
THEN ONE TIME QUESTION THE LOW
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS SO WHAT WHAT ACCOUNTS
FOR THE VARIANCE HERE BETWEEN
THE EXPECTED COST. AND THE REAL
COST OF IN THE END IT IS NOT
ABOUT BLAME IT'S ABOUT HOW CAN
WE ANTICIPATE THESE THINGS
BETTER IN THE FUTURE. RIGHT.
GOOD FOR CAPTAIN STARTED SHE'S
REAL. I THINK ABOUT ORIGINAL
ANALYSIS WAS REALLY JUST BASED
ON ALL WHAT WE BELIEVE- WE NEED
TO DO TO YOUR EMPLOYMENT. WHY
SB ONE THIRTY TWO YEAR OLD- WAS
REQUIRING BUT AS WE WORKED
WITH- YEAH WE CAN SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL AND ALSO WITH OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS THROUGHOUT THE
DEPARTMENT WE REALIZED BUT THAT
REALLY WASN'T SUFFICIENT OR
MEANINGFUL IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE BILL SO THAT OUR
TRANSGENDER INTERSEX NON BINARY
POPULATION- IN ADDITION TO THE
REQUIREMENTS OF SB ONE THIRTY
TWO THIRDS OTHER PLACE THAT'S
ANOTHER PIZZA- THAT. THAT WE
NEED TO TOUCH TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE- REALLY HAVE A GOOD POLICY
PRACTICE THE PLANES JUNE STATE
RETELLS SEARCH- I'M RECOGNIZE.
THIS POPULATIONS GENDER
IDENTITY. AND- IT WHEN WE
REALLY GOT DOWN TO THE WORK
BEHIND IT AND WORK THROUGH ALL
OF THESE PROCESSES LESSON PLANS
THAT NEED TO BE DEVELOPED
ADDITIONAL TRAINING THAT NEEDS
TO BE. DEVELOPED CULTURAL
AWARENESS OR MORE INFORMATION
FOR OUR STAFF ON TRANSGENDER
NON BINARY RESPECTFUL WHAT THAT
EVEN MEANS YOU KNOW- WE REALLY.
THEN WERE ABLE TO- GET OUT OF
BETTER COSTS THE BETTER LOOK
BETTER FOR POSITION. TO SUPPORT
WHAT WE NEED TO DEAL. SURE I
GUESS IS FOLLOW UP WITHOUT
GETTING TOO DEEP INTO THIS IS
WOULD YOU SAY. THAT YOU COULD
HAVE BEEN BETTER CONSULTED AS
THE LEGISLATION WAS GOING
THROUGH I MEAN I'M GONNA SORT
OF LOOKING FOR LESSONS. TO
LEARN HERE- SO THAT BECAUSE
THAT THE MULTIPLES ACTUALLY
QUITE HIGH IN THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN WHAT WAS ESTIMATED THE
TIME IN WHAT IS CLEARLY GOING
TO COST. ALL MY SHARON I CAN
JUMP INTO ON THE OTHER COSTS
FOR SONGS. YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATOR- THIS IS AN BINDING
FROM C. C. R. I. RUN THE
STRATEGIC OF VENDOR MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM- WEDNESDAY- THE INITIAL
ASKED HIM AND I WAS PROVIDED
DETAILS IN TERMS OF JUST
PROVIDING A GENDER IDENTITY
QUESTIONNAIRE AND ONE OF OUR
SYSTEMS- THE ELECTRONIC RECORDS
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM- AND THAT WAS
IMPLEMENTED- AT THE FIRST OF
THE YEAR TO MAKE SURE THAT AND
SHANNON HAD MENTIONED- TO MAKE
SURE THAT QUESTION NEVER GOT
IN. UNDER THE AUSPICES OF BOTH
SB ONE THIRTY TWO AND- THE PRE-
IMPLEMENTATION AS CAPTAIN STARK
AND ALSO MENTIONED THE WORK
GROUP THAT HAD BEEN- WORKING ON
FOR YEARS I HAD STAFF MEMBERS
ON THAT WORK GROUP IS WELL AS
SOME OF MY- TECHNICAL EXPERTS
IN THE IN THE FIELD OF. THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE SOFTWARE
ITSELF I'M COMING UP WITH
REQUIREMENTS- NOT UNTIL
SEPTEMBER OF LAST YEAR WERE THE
REQUIREMENTS PUT FORTH IN TERMS
OF- BEING ABLE TO PUT A GENDER
IDENTITY QUALIFIER INTO THE
SYSTEM AS WELL AS THE PRONOUNS
AND HONORIFICS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY THERE. CURRENTLY THE
STRATEGIC UNDER MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM THAT IS REALLY THE
BEHEMOTH OF MANAGING ON THE
OFFENDER MANAGEMENT WITHIN CCR
ACROSS THE STATE CURRENTLY ONLY
HAS THE GENDER IDENTITY OF MALE
OR FEMALE. SB ONE THIRTY TWO
AND- DECEMBER WE ADDED THE
GENDER IENTITY FIELD THAT
WOULD- ALLOW US TO IDENTIFY THE
OFFENDER OR THE INMATE AS
EITHER MALE FEMALE OR NON
BINARY. AND THERE'S MULTIPLE
PHASES THAT WE HAVE TO GO
THROUGH SO WE HAVE- NOT ONLY
NEED TO UPDATE WHICH IS A HUGE
APPLICATION WE ADDED THAT THE
FIRST GENDER IDENTITY QUALIFIER
ONE SCREEN. WE HAVE TO ALSO
HAVE THAT ON MULTIPLE SCREENS
ABOUT SEVENTY SCREENS AND THE
REASON WE NEED TO DO THIS IS WE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT STAFF USED
THE AND MAKE PREFERRED PRONOUNS
AND HONORIFICS CORRECTLY AND
THEY'RE NOT. WE DON'T HAVE
GENDER ON. ONE SCREEN VERSES
THE GENDER IDENTITY ARE NOT.
THERE'S AND THEN DOWNSTREAM
HAVE OTHER APPLE. ARE USED BY
CASTING STAFF THAT. INFORMATION
FROM. SUCH AS THE- TO YOU AND
THERE'S SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
HAVE THEM PULL THE GENDER
IDENTITY QUALIFIER AS WELL SO
THEY ARE LOOKING AT THE SAME
DATA SAID WE DON'T HAVE ONE
SYSTEM SAYING MALE FEMALE AND
THE OTHER SYSTEM SAYING. MALE
FEMALE OR- FOR NON BINARY SO.
THAT WAS REALLY THE INCREASE OF
THE COST TO THE NUMBER OF
APPLICATIONS WE HAVE ABOUT SIX
PRETTY LARGE APPLICATIONS WE
HAVE TO MAKE THESE CHANGES TO.
AS WELL AS THE OTHER ITEM THE
CAPTAIN STARK MENTIONED IN
TERMS OF THE- THE HOUSING AND
THE OTHER SEARCH PREFERENCES A
WHOLLY DIFFERENT PROCESS. THAT
WILL INCLUDE SOME PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT PROGRAM TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE THAT FUNCTION WITHIN
SONGS HOPEFULLY THAT HELPS.
YOU'RE CERTAINLY CONVEY THE
COMPLEXITY OF THIS CHALLENGE-
THAT DOES HELP THANKS VERY MUCH.
VERY WELCOME. THANKS SENATE
NOTHING OKAY. LET ME JUST SAY
COMPRISES OF THEIR PRESENTATION
OVERALL- BOTH OF BOTH THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PRESENTED THANK
YOU. YEAH I APPRECIATE THAT
SOMETIMES QUESTIONS DON'T MAKE
A LOT OF SENSE WITHOUT HAVING
THE BACKGROUND THAT YOU'VE THAT
YOU'VE DONE. OKAY THAT IT NO
MORE AND LEAVE ANYBODY OUT
AGAIN. NOT ALL RIGHT GREAT I
THINK WE WANT TO PUBLIC COMMENT
OKAY SO LET ME READ OUT HERE.
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ANYONE
WANTING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT REGARDING THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL. AS
A REMINDER TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. 844-291-6364 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE FOUR ONE
SEVEN SIX ZERO NINE. DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIRS MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY TODAY I'M GOING TO
ASK THAT EACH MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC. PROVIDING COMMON KEEP
THEIR REMARKS WITHIN ONE MINUTE.
NOW LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. THE NON. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WHICH TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT.
WHERE IS THE ROOT OF THERE'S
NOBODY THERE OKAY OF NOW WILL
MOVE- IN ON TWO WITNESSES-
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THEN WE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU LINE TWENTY THREE HAS
OF THE PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
BRIAN SPENCER ON BEHALF OF
TRIPLE P. AMERICA WILL BE IS A
LEADER IN THE INDUSTRY A PARA
EDUCATION AND CREATED THE
EVIDENCE BASED ON MIND POSITIVE
PARENTING SYSTEM HELPS PARENTS
DEVELOPS ALL PAIRING SKILLS TO
MANAGER CHILDREN'S BEHAVIOR
PARTICULARLY IN THE PRESENCE OF
HIGH FAMILY STRESS NOTABLY WHAT
MAY OCCUR WITH INCARCERATED
PARENTS. WITH THAT WILL BE IS
SUPPORTIVE OF THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSAL TO INCLUDE INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY IN PRISONS AND
PURCHASING LAPTOPS FOR USE BY
ACADEMIC PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS
ARBITRABILITY WOULD LIKE TO
INSURE AT LEAST REQUEST THAT
THIS TECHNOLOGY NOT BE LIMITED
TO ACADEMICS BUT ALSO ALLOW
INMATES TO ACCESS ONLINE. IN
RICHMOND PROGRAMS SUCH AS ALL
MY PARENT EDUCATION COURSES
SHOVEL PS CURRENTLY WORKING
WITH THE STATE OF ARIZONA TO
HELP INCARCERATED PARENTS
IMPROVE THEIR PARENTING SKILLS
AND MANAGE FAMILY STRESS DURING
AND AFTER INCARCERATION WE
BELIEVE SOMETHING SIMILAR COULD
BE IMPLEMENTED AND VERY
BENEFICIAL HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU. FOR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU. MODERATE BEFORE YOU
OR UP THE FOR A FOR THE CRIME
CAN YOU GIVE ME THE- TOTAL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING TO
TESTIFY PLEASE. THERE IS
CURRENTLY ONE PERSON IN HE-
COMMENT QUEUE. OKAY PLEASE GO
AHEAD MODERATOR. LINE SIXTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
SANDERS THIS IS ANTHONY MARTINO
WITH CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY
AND JUSTICE WE ARE STRONG
SUPPORT THE CLOSURE DVI IN OUR
TWENTY SEVENTEEN REPORT TITLED
SHAPING SOUND HE CALLED FOR THE
CLOSURE FIVE PRISONS AND
REALLOCATION OF SEEING HER
REENTRY SERVICES SUCH AS HOW
THE- ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE SUPPORT. AS WELL AS
INCREASED SERVICES FOR VICTIMS
OF CRIME WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE KENNEDY
ADMINISTRATION OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THE
CLOSURE DVI IN OTHER PRISONS AS
WELL AS REINVESTING SAVINGS IN
A SHARED SAFETY INFRASTRUCTURE
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR CALLING. MONTEREY
ANY. THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. OKAY- CAN
YOU PLEASE CHECK ONCE AGAIN TO
BE SURE WE HAVE HEARD FROM ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. THANK
YOU- PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
IF YOU HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT.
ONE MOMENT WE DO HAVE ONE
PERSON QUEUING UP. GO AHEAD. L.
THAT WILL COME FROM. LINE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE NUMBERS TEN
EUROPEANS HAS ONLY HAPPENED THE
CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA I WE'RE HERE TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL AND- ISSUE NUMBER ONE
THIRTEEN TO TWELVE POINT ONE
MILLION PROPOSED PROBATION
DEPARTMENT FOR THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE RELEASE OF
INDIVIDUALS FROM PC R. AS PART
OF COLLUDED NINETEEN MEASURES-
WE USED TO RELY ON THESE
PARTICULAR RESOURCES TO FILL IN
GAPS IN SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
THE PROVISION THAT COMES FROM
EARLY RELEASE SAYS. AND WE KNOW
THAT THE SPENDING FOLLOWS THE
FORMULA PREVIOUSLY USED TO
ADDRESS LOCAL IMPACT WHEN
YOU'RE REALLY REPEAT THAT HAVE
BEEN DONE- AND WE ARE VERY MUCH
COMMITTED TO LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THIS COMMITTEE THE
LEGISLATURE IN ADMINISTRATION-
ON- DISCUSSING AND ADDRESSING
THE IMPACTS GOING FORWARD THANK
YOU. THANK. YOU PATIENT. MY
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE THERE'S ONE ELSE IN.
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. AND CAN YOU.
ANNOUNCER AGAIN. CERTAINLY IF
THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT IT'S ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD IF YOU'RE
ON A SPEAKER PHONE PLEASE PICK
UP YOUR HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING
THE NUMBERS ONE AND ZERO
THERE'S ONE MORE PERSON QUEUING
UP AT THIS TIME IT'LL BE A
MOMENT WHILE WE GET THEM THERE
LINE NUMBER. THANK YOU. AND WE
GO TO LINE TWENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS JIM LINDBERG AND I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
FRENCH COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
A CALIFORNIA- WE WELCOME THE
RECENT THE CARD THE CARD
SURVATION TREND AND THE PLANS
TO CLOSE PRISON. HAVING BEEN
PRESENT DURING CALIFORNIA'S
PRISON BUILDING BOOM- THE
CLOSURE OF PRISON IS HISTORIC
AND WE COMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION AS WELL
AS THE VOTERS FOR MAKING THIS
POSSIBLE. MOVING FORWARD IN THE
SHORT TERM WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO RAMP UP
INVESTMENT SERVICES TO SUPPORT
PEOPLE COMING OUT OF PRISON. SO
THAT THEY DON'T WIND UP BACK IN
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
OVER THE LONG RUN WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT THE
MASS INCARCERATION PARADIGM OF
THE EIGHTIES AND NINETIES. IS
ROOTED IN INSTITUTIONAL RACISM.
AND IS THE DESCENDANT OF THE
LEGACY OF SLAVERY. FURTHERMORE
OUR CORRECTIONS SYSTEM IS
FUNDAMENTALLY BASED ON
PUNISHMENT- WHICH IS
DESTRUCTIVE TO INDIVIDUALS AND
ENTIRE COMMUNITIES. WERE ARMING
CONNECT BEEN COMMITTED- THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD EMBRACE
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE WHICH HOLDS
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE TRANSFORMS
INDIVIDUAL AND BEGINS THE HILL
COMMUNITY- WE WOULD LIKE TO
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO
MAKE WAS CONSTRUCTED HEARDON
SHIP THE REALITY. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR CALLING
IN. MODERATOR COULD YOU ASK ONE
MORE TIME PLEASE. CERTAINLY IF
THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
IT'S ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. THERE'S NO
ONE IN THE COMMENT Q. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL OF THE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC SENATORS DO YOU
HAVE ANY FINAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. I DO NOT WELL DONE
OKAY FRAZIER I. DON'T HAVE ANY
OTHER SPECIFIC QUESTIONS IN MY
ONLY COMMENT WOULD BE WILL LOOK
FOR TO GET ENOUGH THE
INFORMATION. ON ALL THESE OPEN
ITEMS- AHEAD OF THE NEXT
HEARING THANK YOU VERY. THANK
YOU TO EVERYONE WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU ARE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE. YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US THAT WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD. THANK
YOU WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANKS TO
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE'VE CONCLUDED THE
AGENDA FOR TODAY'S HEARING OF
THE SENATE BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER